[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
and it's great to have a little
afternoon baseball here as we've got the
st louis cardinals getting set to take
on the milwaukee brewers is the mlb game
of the week pregame show presented by
state firm it's the youtube show as a
matter of fact and honestly should be a
lot of fun to watch these teams get
after because corbin burns coming off
the il making his first start since
april 26th he is facing jack flaherty
who has been tremendous he threw seven
scoreless innings against the rockies on
friday holding colorado three hits in a
five-nothing victory that game is coming
up about three minutes from now and this
is a huge get for us big you know in
hollywood when they talk about like you
know booking agents is publicist like
you got mark derosa to do the show you
just knocked up three hours at mlb
central not here to do a youtube show
you requested this right we don't give
me credit where it isn't due we dumbed
it down to two hours today that's right
so i had the extra hour i knew this was
on my schedule i'm going to speak with
elsa afterwards
we'll figure this out i'm dialed in for
this pitching matchup seriously this
yeah my dad always said the game begins
and ends on the mound yes you got two of
the best internationally going at it
today no question admit work alongside
mark derosa we are going to get into
that pitching match in just a second but
first off in case you missed it the
highlights from last night
tyler o'neal over two tonight
and o'neil lifts a high fly ball out
deep right it may go good
the game is tied
shaw to right center it's headed for the
gap it's down
travis shaw [ __ ] had double in the age
[Applause]
comes up with a 4-1 victory as we take a
look at the nl central standings listen
even the bucks they got off to a decent
start now i've slipped a little bit but
only six and a half games separate first
to last and the cardinals and bruins
specifically look really good atop this
division right now st louis has been on
a real run after a slowest start paul
gorsuch's been great for them tyler
o'neill and milwaukee starting pitching
has been ridiculous and just wait until
they get christian yelich back at some
point this season as d-rose said though
the pitching is really where the focus
is corbin burns so this guy has yet to
throw a walk this season i wonder if
he's going to be thinking about that i
think that's a part of it
like a hitting streak i agree he's three
away from tying a break and kelly
jansen's record the amount of strike
hits before allowing a walk so in your
head you're thinking right three more
three more let's go i i'm with you i can
remember what greg maddox was going on a
streak like this and and bobby cox came
out the right move was to intentionally
walk
a guy to break up this streak and mad
dog's going nowhere he asked him he goes
are you okay with it doggy's like yeah
put them on see i would have been
selfish said no
under absolutely no circumstance bobby
get back in that dugout as for the
pitching bachelor seriously burns and
flaherty flurry's a six-game winner so
far he's bounced back after an
unsuccessful 2020 season and burns now
is elite level pictures yeah burns is
throwing stuff we've never seen i mean
just total buzz saw sinkers and sliders
jack flaherty for me you look look at
certain players that were affected by
the pandemic shortened season yeah it
affected jack flaherty we can dive into
the breakdown right now i think it
affected the way he went about attacking
left-handed hitters you take a look in
2019 you could argue argue he was the
best pitcher in the game i mean he had a
second half like jake arrieta had with
the chicago cubs in 15 and 16 the stuff
of legends where you just don't get hit
everything is perfectly placed and then
2020 it kind of got sideways for him
right his first start was around july
24th july 26th and then all of a sudden
he didn't start again to august 19th i
got a chance to talk to him at 30 30 and
kind of go inside how he prepares things
he does off the field mindset wise to
get ready there's different breathing
techniques that go on before i get out
there and then there's just that
you know digging deep and finding that
finding that energy of uh
i don't really know how to explain it
but just finding being able to find that
that mindset in that mode that works for
you every pitcher is different every
player is different and how they you
know how they can attack a game um
for me i'm i'm right here and that's
just the way i have to go about it
moses can we pause this real quick
because i want to make that point i
think christian yelich took it on the
chin javi baez certainly took it on the
chin certain guys creatures of habit
that that 60 game season really affected
certain guys
i think that affected a madman but the
way he attack attacked left-handed
hitters in 19 and 21 very similar in 20
for some reason
he was throwing his heaters and if i
could get in here real quick before we
talk about tunneling carlos payne he
always talks about tunneling but what is
it right you want to throw the heater up
top
and then you want to give the illusion
of another heater up top throwing the
braking stuff off of it in the same
tunnel but against left-handed hitters
he was living down in the zone with
everything so none of them had to
respect anything from belt up
hard or soft they could set their sights
down and as long as they didn't swing at
his slider in the dirt they were more
effective and lefties gave him a little
bit more trouble in 2020. he's back to
work in that north south south mentality
run it
you can't cover all this you can't cover
17 inches and cover 96 now this pitch is
going to come right off that same plane
and it disappears at 80. this next one
to my man alex avila is awesome heater
in 95 and then we're gonna throw a
slider right off that that is just
absolutely unhittable again
to big city right here matt adams
doesn't look right in that colorado
union he needs to come dugouts and get
back in st louis i couldn't agree more
but he's been dominant to the
left-handed hitter something that kind
of jumped out with eric nay's researcher
to the stars breaking it down
he's on top of his game again you see
right here last three seasons
it's basically back to 2019. 591 ops now
down to a 567 and you see in 2020 that's
a
throw that out uh nays is great as is
elijah ackerman our researcher just told
me my era jack flaherty 763 ops against
lefties last year this year 562. when
you're talking about 200 point
differential that's pretty insane and
math is not even our strong suit no
great stuff there from d-ro poll
questions leading up to this youtube
game today real simple here okay who's
going to win the game cardinals are the
brewers you saw diro breaking down the
greatness of flaherty 6-0 2.83 era burns
has been ridiculous making his first
start since april 26th he threw into a
net every day during quarantine and
worked on his wife's peloton as well so
this could be a huge endorsement for
peloton if he pitches well today corbin
burns a lot of focus on this 49
strikeouts prior to issuing his first
walk of the season still to come we've
got some great interviews here lined up
milwaukee brewers
lorenzo cain ridiculous what he did
yesterday he scored from second on a sac
fly gonna ask him about that plus a
great youtuber a sensational mlb the
show giant phillies fan finn for the win
those guys and more coming up next
kane back in there last appeared in the
contest on the 13th of april swinging a
high drive center field wow welcome back
lorenzo kane
that's a return
there's a base hit back up the middle
and dubal around third on his way to the
plate king's throw is close
and not again i'm saying he got him
he is out all right we go wow
sends one in the ear right side foul
territory and tyrone taylor with a
sliding catch for out number one
1-0 pitch to hauser and hauser sends
this one in the air deep right field
racing back is cooper at the track he
has done it again
adrian hauser goes deep
off of castano again adrian houser
lightning strikes twice against castano
see how sharp hater will be after
sitting for a week
let's fly it a swing at a miss and there
you go
and there's strikeout number 400 fastest
in major league history josh hader
welcome back to mlb game of the week
pregame show presented by state farm
and when you look at defensive run save
leaders among outfielders since the
start of the 2018 season mookie betts
the head of the class but right there is
lorenzo kane out of aaron judge kevin
kiermeier and harrison bader and
speaking of harrison bader that's we're
going to start as you bring in lorenz
okay the milwaukee brewers because
yesterday and one of the craziest places
in a while it's bader in center field
and you scored lorenzo on a sac fly how
were you able to do that
oh you know just uh you know initially i
saw him you know go back on the ball so
i was ready to tag and then i saw him
slip so i was unsure what was going to
happen but uh he eventually made the
catch i was able to get back tagged and
uh like i'm always hustling all the way
through and um jason lane did a great
job of waving me home there it's amazing
to be able to do that seriously score a
sacrifice from the second how fired up
were your teammates craig council
everyone in the dugout
yeah everybody was fired up you know um
like i said we were trying to add any
kind of boost to this team right now you
know because you know things haven't
been going the way we wanted but uh
we're going to keep you know battling
and keep grinding out there and
hopefully things start to change makes
me think of that great run from first
base 2015 alcs remember that
oh yeah you know i'm i'm the type of guy
you know i like to hustle on the base
you know um i try to make it tough on a
third base coach as as uh whether to
decide to wave me or or hold me up so uh
like i'm always putting pressure on my
third base coach so uh you know always
trying to score a run for this team
anyway any way possible now that was an
amazing image we're watching again right
now the fact you turned 35 you're still
fast i can applaud you on behalf of all
the rest of us slowpokes out there um
let's focus on the starting pitching
which has been amazing so far this
season i think we all knew how good
brandon woodruff is but corbin burns has
gone to a next level what has been the
difference for burns
yeah i mean for me you know he's he's
throwing all his pictures you know
cutters at i don't know 96 97 98 so uh
they say the guy's filthy you know um
he's definitely fun to play behind you
know our entire pitching staff is it's
been lights out so uh you know as a
group as a whole this pitching staff
this bullpen those guys have been doing
a great job all year long and uh as a
defender you know it's fun to play
behind them and you always want to make
plays for those guys and burn still
hasn't allowed a walk i mean in this day
and age how crazy is that kind of
pinpoint control
yeah it's it's it's very impressive you
know what he's doing is very impressive
um i mean like i said it's just fun to
watch right now and um you know you kind
of feel bad for the hitters sometimes
but uh
he's he's definitely lights out he's
dominating the game right now and uh i
think he can he can definitely keep this
going for a very long time offensively
right now it's been a grind and part of
that is you're missing christian yellow
how critical is that to getting him back
in this lineup healthy and productive
yeah you know you know we're having you
know yellows in the lineup is always
always a good thing you know um he's
he's battling his tail off to get back
in the lineup uh he's he's working every
day in the training room make sure he's
you know getting his back you know right
and um i mean you know we definitely
miss him out there but at the same time
you know we got to go out there and
battle as a team um you know got to
continue to pull for each other you know
stay together regardless of what's
happening right now we got we got to
stick with each other and hopefully
things start to change for sure it's
amazing lorenzo you often see turnover
in the game but in the nl central the
last five years every time it's a tight
race you feel like anybody can win and
the the separation being top and bottom
is very few games any ideas why your
division is so tightly contested every
year
i don't know i just just the division as
a whole you know um i don't know just
playing each other everybody's very
competitive um
you know i think pitching is is is
lights out nowadays um i think it's
getting tougher and tougher but at the
same time you know
in our division you know from top to
bottom it's it's just a battle and uh
you know everybody's very competitive
ready to compete each each day and uh i
think it's gonna be that way the rest of
this year so hopefully we come out on
top but uh yeah it's definitely gonna be
a grind the rest of the year been
watching and enjoying your career for
many years so i need your help right now
which pun do you prefer with regards
your last name is it citizen kane
rosebud is it kane is able is it big
daddy kane uh raising kane yeah which
one do you like the most
oh wow um
wow oh man i've heard all of them um
i guess i like kane is able you know um
kane is able to go out and get the job
done you know
you know all all parts of the field you
know defensive uh stealing bases you
know swinging the bat so i like kane is
able you know a guy that's able to go
out there and get the job done in all
phases
my sister-in-law is actually from
wisconsin she's in franklin wisconsin
she's close to milwaukee so she's you
know packers fan all the rest of it and
i love the fish fry i get to milwaukee
whenever i can but i understand you are
a big dallas cowboys fan how do you feel
about the cowboys how they did in the
draft
oh man i i think they had a great draft
um they addressed a lot of needs um
you know cornerback linebacker you know
michael parsons is going to be a beast
uh kevin joseph as well um i think we
did a great job and i'm definitely
excited to root my cowboys on i'll
definitely be to a few games and i'm
definitely excited for the season start
for sure well let's hope dak prescott is
healthy for your sake cowboy's at the
box to open the nfl season which should
be a lot of fun but right now we're
focusing on baseball i hope the brew
crew keeps making some noise lorenzo
cain thanks so much for the time man
appreciate you
all right thanks for having me
time now for a creator spotlight
somebody who loves the game like no
one's business and that's weak it is
finn mcconnell the finn ftw that's right
the finn for the win
live commentary and gameplay of a
variety of sports video games such as
emily the show madden and many more and
his favorite major league baseball
moment it's a great one celebrating the
late great roy halley we'll talk to all
that more as you bring in finn for the
win right now let's start there finn
how'd you come up with that finn for the
win
uh oh it's probably something that came
up when i was about i'd say let's see 15
i think and
uh pretty default name but it rhymed so
i decided to stick with it why not well
i think it's key like when you're using
any sort of acronyms like ftw you have
to figure out what it is like if you're
going wtf that's a different
conversation so i think you're fortunate
the way that we've leaned in these these
acronyms and such ftw everyone's well
aware of what that means
exactly there are some people that still
have no idea what it what it means but
um i'm happy to answer it because
luckily it isn't an appropriate acronym
no question about it let's dive into
your fandom for the phillies and that
specific moment you love roy holiday
being from toronto i love watching
holiday for so many years at the blue
jays then he goes to phillies and
continues to dominate and felt like it
was almost a different audience that got
to appreciate how great doc was that
came in 2010 particularly a no-hitter
you get to meet him after the game tell
me all about that experience
oh it was such a surreal game for sure
and uh we actually were sitting in right
field 200 level you know right above the
the signs out there and uh i remember
what was crazy the most is i actually
had a fall ball game uh that day and
luckily it got cancelled so we got to
stick around and see that moment but the
best the best moment of the game for
sure was that swinging bunt right there
from brandon phillips i mean you could
have heard a pin drop
during that at-bat when that ball was
put in play it was absolutely surreal
and then the whole place just erupted
when the final alcohol was made but i
got to meet him after the game we
actually uh back when i was in middle
school my dad and i used to stay after
and try and get autographs after the
game and i was lucky enough to get to
meet him and get him to sign a warm-up
ball he actually tossed me in the
bullpen before uh before heading out
there and we we actually ended up
staying there probably i think we got
home around 1am that night
amazing story i mean listen doc an
intense guy but clearly a great player
and i'm glad you got to have that moment
with him take me back when did you first
become such a die-hard phillies fan
i went to my first game in uh 2006. i
can't quite remember who the team was
that they took on but uh i remember
that's when i i was never really a
sports guy up until i went to my first
baseball game and then i just i fell in
love with the game started liking hockey
and football but to me nothing's gonna
top
baseball for sure and i've been going to
baseball games ever since
uh what was it about the game that you
think entranced you so much
i don't know it's just it's completely
different apart from every other you
know sport out there at least you know
the big four just seems to be going back
and forth but baseball is just such a
different ball game and i in my opinion
takes a lot more skill and there's you
know so many more uh
skills that need to you need to have to
play the game it's it's not just about
shooting a puck or being able to stop a
puck or
throw a ball and catch a ball you have
to be able to hit you have to be able to
catch you have to be able to throw pitch
depending on you know what your
positions are it's just so so much more
of a multi-tool game that's well said i
will be now one of our shows here at the
network is the show for the thinking fan
baseball is that sport for the thinking
fan the phillies this season what have
you been impressions of this team so far
inconsistent to put it into one term for
sure but uh that whole division it's
actually funny because uh they should
start calling it what they were calling
the the nfc east uh last year for
football the nl leased because it's it
was supposed to be the most hyped
division this year and they've been it's
been kind of disappointing so i really
don't know who's going to end up on top
i really think it's a toss-up for
i don't know so much about the marlins
but i think all five teams could
possibly get it it's still very early in
the season but
definitely definitely a toss up but your
perception is accurate because i felt
the same way this will be very
competitive division instead it's been a
lot of mediocrity although that seems to
be league wide especially when it comes
to hitters struggling at the plate what
do you make of the fact batters are
hitting like 2 30 this season
yeah it's weird but another odd thing
about you mentioning batting averages
it's it's i feel like it's actually
becoming a pretty obsolete stat a lot of
people are talking ops right now which
i'm old school i'm not a big fan of that
i still i still judge a batter way more
based on his batting average than his
ops so i'm more of an old school guy but
um but yeah i definitely don't like
seeing guys hitting lower especially if
they're not putting up a lot of uh
a lot of balls over the fence yeah i'm
with you when a guy's hitting 235 right
now you can say well that's above
average that just doesn't feel right uh
let's get to your youtube channel at
least 40 dingers yeah exactly like pete
and kavilia back in the day uh let's get
to your youtube page obviously you're a
guy who cares a lot about being active
with social media being young people etc
uh what was all the effort that you put
into putting together your youtube page
oh i probably started my channel back
when i was uh let's see yeah like 15 16
i think i started making it i i made
pretty
amateur videos with like cheap uh you
know recording software i had and then i
really got serious with it probably
towards the end of 2015 i started doing
nhl and it went really well then i
started doing mlb and that's probably
been my far to record for sure but um
i've started doing daily uploads every
day streaming almost every day and i i
have a lot of fun with it no complaints
at all yeah last one i've noticed with
mlb the show you like to create your own
character dorsal fin is your guy who is
your favorite player you like to model
your game after
i really just like to do my own thing
there's not really anyone i i try to be
like i kind of just try to be the best
of that position or best in the league
pretty much i don't try like this year
i'm doing a two-way player that's a
newer feature in the game so i try to
just be the best pitcher and the best
sitter
uh out of everyone in the league
finn for the win last one anyone call
you huck is there anybody old enough
that thinks huckleberry finn when they
see your name i probably get everything
other than finn and not too many people
call me finn i get finnegan dorsal i get
uh finley and pretty much everyone calls
me anything other than finn we talk
again i'm calling you huck finn for the
win great stuff man
yeah thank you for having me appreciate
it
all right great stuff there for my man
huck finn
carbon burns is getting set he has been
lights out so far this season leads the
majors with a 42 percent whiff rate this
season when we come back we'll put deer
on the spot your picks to click
don't go anywhere
yanks it down the left field line will
it stay fair it is hooking and it is
caught up against the wall what a catch
what a catch
justin williams
and he smokes it one-nothing cardinals
he almost broke the side and left field
you can hear that up here this is gonna
go from questionable foul ball to
souvenir you're calling it yeah
[Applause]
are you calling it i'd like to see it
well everybody would like to see it i
want to know if you're calling it okay
why not
goldsmith
then goes
into left
two-run
there's a swing and a high fly ball it's
a deep left field clarity has just hit a
home run
his first major league home run
[Applause]
all right except for the mlb game of the
week pregame show presented by state
farm so we got the cardinals and jack
flair to get said take on corbin
[Music]
all right getting set for some picks to
click here as it is the mlb game of the
week pregame show presented by state
farm admin brook alongside mark derosa
so we've talked a lot about jack
flaherty how great he's been time for
picks to click brought to you by bet mgm
question now becomes this stero when you
think of a cy young favorite this year
okay who's your favorite to win the sa
young because obviously flaherty is in
that conversation is he the guy for you
it's garrett cole after what i watched
him do last night i know we're in a
wrong league correct
it's jacob to groms as long as he's
healthy but what jack flaherty's done in
the early going the 6-0 i mean it can't
be denied corbin burns the guy he's
taking on plus 450 on the odds i like
brandon woodruff his teammates plus 1800
i like that as well bauer walker buehler
giving you six plus at plus 2 000.
mm-hmm not sure i like the money on
flash exactly flaherty for plus 3 000.
that's good i like where your head's out
on this st loses offense picking it up
he's been great so far okay those are
your rods degrom obviously heavy
favorite minus one two five but burns
bauer some other good choices there as
well all right um who's your favorite to
win the pennant
everyone thought dodgers and also they
fell apart i hate the predictions it's
the one thing i i i seem to get wrong i
think it's because on central they'll
bring it back yeah i've had the atlanta
braves to win the entire thing and
atlanta got your exploratory surgery and
no closer i'm a little concerned
pitching's been a mess
that's the problem braves are still plus
800 by the way i'll tell you who's
jumping out at me and i know they're hot
right now seven in a row the new york
man yeah the metropolitan journey on i
as long as jacob degrom comes back they
have every weapon to get it done and
beat a team that no one's going to want
to play
still early right we haven't seen
honestly how was he by the way he was
great he actually he's thinking gary
cohn's called the king of the walk up
fielder's choice
[Laughter]
tywin walker great signing two years 20
million
great signing this guy's lights out he's
been great for the match stroman as well
other former jay all right so mets as we
like there how about over under total
runs scored in today's game minus six
and a half with two outstanding pitchers
on the mound
i mean it screams that it should be
three two ball game but i'm going never
that yeah that's what you say you're
gonna go the other way yeah paul
goldschmidt's going to the slide
at some point in this game on a
two-seamer it's the ballpark miller park
well it's now american family field
thank you it's one of the greatest
ballparks to hit in from an offensive
player and as long as it's i know it's a
day game as long as i got the panels
open and the shadows don't get too skewy
you're going to see something go out of
this yard
here are not about it both at 368 there
so interesting how that park plays where
did you always hit well what was your
favorite part to hit it i should put it
that way dodger stadium i love minute
maid yeah
danielle central's got some bam boxes in
it cincinnati right wrigley
yeah why i keep saying miller american
family field so no this is one of the
better ones yeah central's always fun
and i'm with you whenever it feels a
certain way go the other way feel like
everyone said colorado they love playing
colorado i had trouble breathing that
altitude i had a jammer in 2008 i almost
didn't make it but we're here it's no
joke man that all to do will get you
i'm serious and the turbulence going
into that place is
nightmare not great not great um who's
going to win today's game cardinals 63
well think about that fan base they're
they're active they're on youtube
they're everywhere the cardinals when i
look at the nl central uh one word comes
to mind trust who do you trust and i
trust the names on the roster of st
louis cardinals maybe not today yeah
michael brew crew for the steel today
with burns on the mound i like that but
i think when when the dust settles uh st
louis is going to win this debate
goldschmidt ridiculous 1185 ops all-time
in american family field to your point
about certain guys love certain ways
yeah let's take a look at the lineup i
know you want to look at the livestream
specifically see how it's looking so you
got tommy edmond dylan carlson gold lee
arnotto really top heavy there for the
cardinals and the brewers my man colt
wong he's only two for eleven two walks
his first three games against his former
team lorenzo kane they gotta get yelich
back one of these days and that scares
me the back is always a tricky thing and
not only do they got to get yelich back
the name they got to get the 40 homer
version of christian yelich back
speaking of adam mccalvey tweeting this
christian yelts will go on a rehab
assignment triple a national beginning
tomorrow and the brewers will reassess
after the weekend asked whether that
means to be back for next week's series
at kc council said tbd i just want to
get through the weekend first that's a
good sign no that is a good sign the
fact that he came back it scared the
heck out of me one day didn't like the
way he felt yeah when that's what i'm
talking about like a situation with mike
soroco the pitcher for the atlanta
braves for him too as a young man to
walk in and say something's not right
something's not right because you know
the difference between
injury and a pain that you can maybe
work through but that division deal with
nlcentral always feels like
three games separate four teams right
the last five years you look at your
team runs away with it and cincinnati
seems to be sitting at 500 and i don't
understand why they can't figure out a
way to like they're both really go i i
understand that but they can match
you're certainly talented and mash
again i keep coming back to st louis
because i trust the guys in their lineup
i like their lineup i think tommy edmond
at the top dylan carlson's the prospect
that everyone's waiting to just explode
four and a half games separating the top
four teams yeah
when people talk about cardinal nation
some people think like it rubs in the
wrong way it's a little bit arrogant
right like hey best fans in the game
what was your take when you were playing
did you get a sense of that and said
yeah i just respected the ball game
respected guys who hustled and played
hard and played the game fundamentally
sound the right way
listen
i say this all the time it's no it's
just glorified little league
we still know who the best players are
albert pujols in 2009 i want him to be a
monster and try and go big mac land matt
holiday i want you going big mac land
let us fill in the cracks and get the
buns down and do the hit and runs the
game's kind of changing guys have lost
their way a little bit with the shift
everyone's trying to go
matt holly by the way is on the call
today this is fun yeah that's gonna be
fun yeah please second scott braun
holiday i gotta ask you this we gotta
move maddie on the call i want to save
the best for last your boy rofl now has
merch yeah that's a problem like on
instagram last night robert flores has
his own shirt i'm not kidding bro flow
getting away from him
he probably got 100 cotton they shrink
next thing you know they're in a garage
like the quality of the shirt
right it's a schmedium it immediately
goes to crap like what are we doing here
i mean how long
like you played like there's derose in
the back you don't have a hero i have a
front i have an 11 year old son that
does two things he plays baseball and
video games that's what he loves to do
and and row flow this is hero
some nights i wonder if they're on in
cahoots until two in the morning
screaming or doing something
[Laughter]
that's all i gotta say okay dear oh he's
got a jersey on the back real flow's got
his name on the front shahada you're
next this should be a lot of fun cards
and brewers scott braun dan plisack matt
holiday jp morocci on the call thanks to
mark derosa chipping in here youtube
[Applause]
[Music]
are you kidding me
[Applause]
one of the prime pitching matchups in
all of baseball is going down in the
midwest today two flamethrowers with a
daytime duel in bruce city two of the
top teams in the division have one more
clash in the series before heading their
separate ways and today the entire
planet has eyes on the nl central this
is the game of the week live on youtube
presented by state farm in wisconsin the
st louis cardinals match up with the
milwaukee brewers and we are live inside
the studios to call the action scott
braun along with former milwaukee brewer
and three-time all-star dan pleisak
is there anything like daytime action in
milwaukee little tailgate actually no a
little tailgate little bratz and a
marquee pitching matchup corbin burns
who has not walked a single hitter all
season long 49 strikeouts
zero walks we'll watch him work against
jack flaherty all on youtube over 20
exclusive games on youtube this season
let your friends know easy to find us
youtube.com mlb it's free for everyone
it's three million subscribers on mlb's
youtube channel watching today we'll
remind you about upcoming games with a
little notification if you hit the bell
icon youtube tv customers are hooked up
with an mlb pop-up within the channel
guide and look who just popped up for
the entire game with us as well it's
matt holliday the former st louis
cardinal matt it's great to have you on
board and how surreal is this for you to
watch many of your former teammates
today and we'll even talk to one of them
in adam wainwright
what's up guys yeah i'm glad to be here
it's pretty uh pretty exciting to
get a chance to watch some of my old
teammates even though yachty is is
getting soft on me and set out the one
game i get to do so uh maybe we'll get a
chance to talk to adam or yachty and and
i'm excited to be here and watch some
some good baseball we have wayno booked
for this one yeah we'll see if we can
grab a little sound from yachty he's
missing out because jack flaherty's on
the mound and he's matching up against
corbin burns who's coming off an injured
list stint he was covered positive he's
back dan and like you mentioned he
doesn't walk anywhere i mean it's been
amazing the transformation of corbin
burns bounced around from the rotation
to the bullpen back to the starting
rotation and look at that graphic right
there era of 1.53
29 in the third innings he's yet to walk
a hitter and he's punched out 49 but
it's hard also to believe that one pitch
could turn a guy's game around and
that's what happens with corbin burns
the cutter it's a nasty pitch and it's
iv low 96 to 98 miles an hour equal
opportunity he'll throw at the lefties
he'll throw it to righties he'll throw
it front door he'll throw it back door
you can't sit on one pitch from this guy
this cutter right now might be the most
dominant pitch in the game of baseball
and what he did dan was completely
revamp his repertoire as you can see
this was a four-seam fastball guy in
2019 a very down year for him completely
changed everything and now using the
cutter more than ever
and also on the other end of the
pitching pairing you have jack flaherty
who aside from one clunker on opening
day matt has been fantastic the
four-seam fastball plays up what's the
scatting report on him
you know i think jack flaherty is a guy
that locates his fastball down and away
to righties really well he uh he tunnels
that fastball down and away with his
slider that looks exactly the same and
then kind of dives off the outside
corner uh when you look at his fastball
it's anywhere from 92 all the way up to
97. he kind of uses it with two
different pitches where he can throw the
92 to get ahead in account and then go
reach back and get the 97 late in the
count but to me it's the conviction
which he throws this fastball it's not a
huge spin rate but he throws a ton of 14
fastball the league's only hitting 150
off of it and and it kind of surprises
me when you look at the average against
against a fastball like that but
like i said he's got conviction in his
pitches and he's an all-around just a
really good competitor you can see april
1st against the red six earned runs in
four and a third and since then he's a
lead he's one of the best starters in
the sport he received a ton yeah i think
you talk about that first game uh and
like you said it was a little bit of a
clunker but since then uh his fastball
velocities ticked up in the last couple
games uh up to 97 and and like i said
he's a two pitch pitcher uh mostly
fastball slider he's been dropping in
some curveballs and talking to mike
shield he's been using that pitch a
little bit more often for a change of
pace to get guys off the hard fastball
and the hard slider uh but i i think
when you look at you know the the
conviction in which he throws his
fastball and and the competitor that he
is is kind of what sets him apart and
makes him a top of the rotation kind of
guy matt he can produce some swing and
miss but if there's a ground ball he's
probably in good shape especially at the
hot corner with nolan aronado the
eight-time goal glover and he can swing
the bat a little bit too you have a
special relationship with him what's he
like
you know i think he's just all around
one of the best players in the league
you know like we talked about his
defense um i i knew he was great defense
great at defense but in 2018 when i got
a chance to go back and and play with
him on an everyday basis for about six
weeks it almost seemed like every day he
was making some sort of gold glove play
i saw some plays that i've never seen
before but i think watching him do his
work before the game is what the most
impressive thing to me was and then
obviously is hitting you know i mean
he's a he's a 35 home run 100 rbi guy
he's been an mvp candidate every year
he's played
and i think the one thing that sets him
apart is his tenacity he plays every day
he wants to be in there he plays with
high emotion
it's very important to him he's just a
a very tough competitor
and a guy that you just figure and
you've seen it already the saint louis
crowd will gravitate towards they love
to watch him and then on the other side
with paul goldschmidt at first base it's
a special group over in saint louis over
in milwaukee is our own j.p morocci the
fourth member of our team very lucky guy
very pumped for this pitching matchup jp
thank you scott good afternoon from
american family field in milwaukee
wisconsin our broadcast location out in
left center field a gorgeous afternoon
here in milwaukee just beside us corbin
burns going through his first warm-up
routine for a start in a little more
than two weeks in all the eyes here in
wisconsin throughout the nl central in
the mlb world wondering does his command
return as it was to begin this season at
incredible start he has been on not
issuing a single walk so far very
importantly during that layoff he was
able to keep throwing so we'll see if
that cutter command remains intact that
has already seen him be the starting
pitching leader in terms of most innings
pitched and most strikeouts here in this
case without having issued a walk of
course just two behind ken lee jansen of
the dodgers for the all-time record in
that category a blustery and yet
beautiful day here in milwaukee lineups
in first pitch and nl central showed on
us next on youtube
this is gonna go from questionable foul
ball
[Applause]
the 01.
base head into center
carlson will score
goldsmith to third two-nothing cardinals
and a two-out rally here for st louis
the 2-1 pitch
or renato sent it down the right field
line it's well hit slicing near the
corner and it's down a ground rule
double for nolan arnatto
backhands it
wow come on wow what a quick reaction by
nolan arnotto the pitch to story is hit
hard toward third picked on one hop by
arenato and he throws out his good
friend trevor story nolan aronado facing
his old team
marinado deep left field his first home
run against his former team
let's get into the bullpen
you know he's loving it six home runs
for arnaudo 23 rbis and a seven game
hitting streak
[Music]
this is the mlb game of the week live on
youtube presented by state farm we take
you to american family field as the
milwaukee brewers host the st louis
cardinals the lid wide open nice stay
out in milwaukee wisconsin
nice pitching matchup going on between
jack flaherty and corbin burns coming up
and this is the lineup that burns will
face presented by state farm it's the
starting nine for mike schilt st louis
cardinals with tommy edmond at shortstop
filling in for paul the young today
dylan carlson in right field paul
goldschmidt absolutely terrorizes
milwaukee pitching especially in this
ballpark arenado carpenters in its
second o'neill with a homer in each game
of the series so far vader and center
kisner is going to catch today for jack
flaherty
well there he is the man of the hour
corbin burns we touched on into the open
take a look at that graphic 29 in the
third innings that's right no walks
49 strikeouts that's about as good as he
can strike out the walk ratio he's been
terrific the cutter is his main weapon
and the biggest question will be
any rust coming off about a two-week
layoff he was on the covet injured list
tested positive for covet 19. he said it
was asymptomatic working out at home
working on his wife's peloton to keep
himself in shape and he delivers the
first pitch on the corner for a strike
to tommy edmond to start the day on
youtube and on cue that's the cutter 96
miles an hour what's made him so
effective is he throws that cutter to
both sides of the plate he can throw it
away to a lefty and down and into lefty
also like that one right there matt how
do you
game plan against corbin burns
[Music]
the one thing that that is puzzling is
typically like like dan said is it's a
one side of the plate pitch with the
cutter that a weight of righties and
kind of in the lefties but he's been
able to pitch it to both sides i was
talking to nolan aronado he told me the
tough part about it is that he'll hip
shot the right hand hitter uh and you
can't just kind of look out over the
plate because he does throw the cutter
inside so for me you've got to look one
side or the other you can't chase this
guy back and forth on both sides of the
plate
he's ahead 02 on edmond
who makes contact right side it gets
through and the cardinals have a
lead-off hitter
edmond is aboard and it's time for our
state farm pitching breakdown dan i mean
what more is there to say about corbin
burns so far this year well one of the
keys today is is he going to be rusty
after missing about two and a half weeks
of action he was in such a good groove
and that's the case the cardinals may be
in business the cutter the second bullet
point is his best pitch it's changed him
around he like lucas giolito the white
sox went from a terrible pitcher to a
good pitcher and command in chief if
he's commanding all three of his pitches
he's going to be very very difficult to
get multiple hits in any inning he faced
saint louis
in missouri on the eighth of april six
shutout innings one hit nine strikeouts
and he finds the zone against dylan
carlson
well so far so good if your council
wondering how he's gonna be he's
throwing through four pitches and four
strikes right off the get-go
i think he's gonna have to use his
sinker too i think when you come back
off of injury he's gonna try to need to
make the ball go both ways on these
hitters a little bit maybe show him the
sinker so that they have to at least
respect that he might throw something
beside the cutter
carlson's had big numbers in the first
inning his first at-bat this year
edmond's on the move here's the throw to
second and it is late
a stolen bag for tommy edmond his second
of the series he's swiped one in game
one of this three-game set it's number
six on the season
it's a really good jump right here
nevaeh's really has no shot to throw him
out
corbin burns really paying attention to
carlson and the on deck uh guy that was
hitting
pretty good walking lead there for tommy
edmond
already you're running i think this is a
good approach for
this is a good approach i think against
a really good pitcher is that you get a
guy on early now you steal a base now it
makes carlson's job easy with getting
the ball get getting the runner over
with the ground ball to the right side
and then you have a chance to score
early with a sac flyer or something you
give yourself a chance to score off a
guy like burns early
you feel a lot better if you're jack
flaherty going out there with a lead
against corbin burns
we haven't seen much scoring in the
first two games of this series excellent
starting pitching early on
brandon woodruff and freddie peralta
excellent for milwaukee will actually
talk to woodruff
a couple innings from now and after the
first inning concludes adam wainwright
will join us
[Applause]
nasty cutter
42 whiff rate for corbin burns this
season it's best in major league
baseball that's just good old-fashioned
swing and miss that he's able to produce
two strikes on carlson
burns was a sixth place finisher last
year for the nl cyong award probably
would have rated higher
as
carlson does not bite
carlson
facing a 3-2 count statcast powered by
google cloud shows us how corbin burns
likes to handle his business
with three ball counts dan cutters and
he stays in the zone well that just
shows you how much confidence he has in
that pitch a couple years ago back to
2019
he was basically a four seen fastball
guy up in the zone so he's not afraid to
run deep counts go to that cutter three
and two
and carlson chase is 97 that dips down
and it's the first out of the day well
the streaks alive he's yet to walk a
hitter
carlson might have swung at ball four
right there is a good look at this
cutter you can see that grip and it
looks like fastball all the way the
bottom just falls off off the bottom of
it
that's strikeout number 50. you know
it's crazy as much as he uses this
cutter it's almost like mariano rivera
asking how much he uses it and he's
pissed him basically with one pitch
uh it's it's pretty amazing that you
know he's gonna throw it but you still
can't hit it
it's like a closer but he's pitching all
game long
and going up against paul goldschmidt
number three hitter for st louis
one out in edmond on second
we'll see some of those swings today dan
well that's what's so unique you know as
a hitter that there's a pretty good
chance you're gonna get one of those
cutters but he'll throw it up in the
zone like he did to paul goldschmidt and
then bury that one down and then like he
did to carlson for the strikeout on the
3-2 pitch
goldschmidt makes contact and on the
hands and that's to short for urias
and vogelback will slap the tag on
edmond moves to third with two outs here
in the first and your state farm
defensive alignment for the milwaukee
brewers they pride themselves on their
defense vogelback made a big impact
yesterday wanga gold glover uria's just
made that play
shaw at the hot corner or novaez is back
today activated off the injured list to
play catch with burns and in the
outfield bradley jr kane and garcia with
christian yelich on the injured list but
looks like he's on the comeback trail
again we'll give you more news on yelich
in a bit but he will begin a rehab
outing this weekend in nashville to get
some at bats
that last pitch to goldsmith was the two
seamer
inside and that's the equalizer right
there where he keeps guys off the cutter
a little bit
now arenado gets one pass short and
that's gonna break the ice for the
cardinals
nolan arenado makes it one nothing as
edmond scores
cut her out over
nice swing right there cut her out
overstayed on it light it through the
left side
get a good look too at the value that
stole the base from tommy edmond leads
off the game with a base hit
steal second base able to get over the
third and
nolan aronado
takes his cutter intended to be away
that kind of stays on the inner half of
the plate and drives it right there
between the hole between short and third
again going back to getting after this
guy early in the count he doesn't throw
a lot of balls he doesn't walk people he
pitches
on the plate so there is aggressive
early in the count and try to get a get
a run home right there
just a couple ground balls past the
infield
two hits one run now for st louis and
here comes matt carpenter
3 for 11 with a couple homers in his
career against the starter for milwaukee
it was interesting you think he went
first pitch change up to matt carpenter
right there i think he knows carp is
going to be aggressive early in the
count and he's jumped
jumped him a couple times already a
couple home runs against him so he goes
first pitch change up and then looks
like more of a sinker right there
and that one's lifted to shallow center
kane racing in gonna be a tough play and
it drops
and arenado is going to round third here
comes the throw and it is
in time
arenado's toast at home narvaez slaps on
the tag
it's a base hit for carpenter but that's
going to end the frame lorenzo kane just
an all-around complete player craig
council talking to us this morning about
the impact that he makes on a daily
basis
not there quick enough to make the catch
but saves the run
[Applause]
they wanted arenado to stick around at
third he goes aggressive home and the
brewers prevent one run but the first of
the day is on the board for st louis and
we'll head to the cardinals half of the
first
swing adam is duvall strikes out one and
two on anderson one nothing marlins the
pitch swing and a miss anderson's gone
on strikes here's the 2-2
struck him out looking one two three
inning oh there's a good breaking ball
and rojas down on strikes
1-0 pitch to hauser and hauser sends
this one in the air deep right field
racing back is cooper at the track he
has done it again
adrian hauser goes deep
and the brewers lead it three to one
and a cold strike three
strikeout number five for adrian hauser
and he got him went back to the fastball
anderson slams his bat down
that one's in there called strike three
002 pitch and a swing at a miss
strikeout number eight
going in there again carved him up ninth
strikeout
payoff pitch again
struck him out strikeout number 10 for
adrian hauser
anderson on the first pitch a bouncer to
wall terrific outing for adrian hauser
one nothing cardinals could have been
two if not for luis orios backing up
lorenzo kane dan who definitely sold out
for this baseball really heads up play
we talked to craig council before the
game they really liked the defense and
aureus really johnny on the spot right
there backing up lorenzo kane giving an
opportunity this is a really heads-up
play right here good base driving too by
the cardinals to go ahead and try to get
that second run in it took a good throw
and you can see nolan arenado almost
able to score the cardinals second run
three hits for st louis against burns
most in the first inning of a start over
the last two seasons for him and now
jack flaherty's turn against the
milwaukee starting nine
jack flaherty with a 3-3-2 era in his
career
it's under three so far this season and
really just one bad outing dan his first
outing of the year since then he's gone
6-0 and he's what they look like a big
strong dude a lot of innings a little
bit of a disappointing 2020 season last
year in the 60 game abbreviated schedule
i think the starting and stopping of the
season really hurt jack flaherty but if
the cardinals are going where they want
to go this guy's going to be driving the
bus
a lot of teams in baseball scott feel
like they have an ace pitcher you're
looking at one right here this guy's a
legitimate top 10 pitcher in all of
baseball
it's two balls in a strike to colton
wong okay matt you had a pretty good
game plan in the first against corbin
burns so what's the attack mode for the
brewers against flaherty today
yeah i think for me you got to stay on
the four-seam fastball he's throwing it
a lot i think 50 of the time he's
throwing four-seam fast balls in the
92-95 range probably down and away to
both hitters is his hot spot and i would
just be super aggressive on the fastball
he handles wong lorenzo kane coming up
it's the state farm brewers starting
nine so after wong's kane and vogel back
travis shaw cleaning up he leads the
team in homers and rbi's avaseo garcia
hitting 469 in may after a 195 april
he's been their best bat this month
narvaez just activated today bradley jr
is in the left maria short and corbin
burns in the nine spot
getting a good look there jack flaherty
34th player taking over all the draft in
2014 out of harvard westlake high school
just side of outside of los angeles
how about this for a team how would you
like to have john flaherty lucas giolito
and max freed
all on your high school baseball team
yeah jack lewis and max all on a squad
together for a year jack was a couple
years younger than those two as kane
lifts one out to right
backing up is carlson and he's got it so
your state farm breakdown on jack
flaherty brings you ace-like stuff today
well 6-0 on the year he had a rough one
in his debut against the cardinals and
other key secondary pitches good slider
curveball combination he'll mainly go to
the slider as his secondary pitch then b
and ace and listen every good team and
the cardinals think they are a good team
and that's going to be playing in
october they need an ace and this would
be the race he would be a game one
starter for most teams including the
cardinals
there's a strike to vogelback
and matt it gets brewers are gonna have
to find some offense somewhere
yeah matt it'll get even scarier too i
know we talked to
mike schilt this morning about jack
flaherty's uptick in velocity as the
game continues along and also you
mentioned in the pregame the location
and the conviction that he's brought to
the table
jack is really putting it all together
and he's still so young
yeah you know i think this year he's got
off to a really good start coming off
dan mentioned earlier the the covet
season last year i think he was pretty
disappointed but as we all know the
cardinals had a big problem with kovit
and had to take a couple weeks off and
then kind of getting back into the
groove he never really found his rhythm
as a pitcher and
i know that that right now he's really
coming into kind of that form that we
saw a couple years ago so uh like i said
his fastball will tick up as the game
goes and and and and hopefully uh he can
continue to keep moving that's a great
play by paul goldsmith who plays a mean
first base and gets the job done three
up three down in the first for flaherty
cardinals up one nothing
only kim's third three ball count of the
night
fly ball left center slicing away from
bader it's down
off the warning track into the bullpen
at ground rule double
kane scores
one-nothing brewers
so the go-ahead potential go-ahead run
is at second base and carlson will bet
the 2-2 pitch
from williams is hit in the air to left
field tagging at third is harrison bader
the catch is made in left the throw
coming home and it's not in time the
cardinals have tied it under a third one
out now it's goldsmith first pitch is
hammered
out to deep left
it's at the wall gone
two-run blast for goldie
3-1 st louis
so there's been a lot of traffic in this
11th inning for the cardinals
and that is hammered
into center
at the wall it is
gone tyler o'neal
three-run blast and i smell the coffee
brewing 6-1 cardinals in the 11.
you're watching the mlb game of the week
live on youtube presented by state farm
cardinals have a run after one on the
brewers as we're in milwaukee scott
braun dan please sack matt holliday and
j.p marosi and time now for our dugout
interview presented by state farm and
our youtube creators in the live chat
hit us up with some questions for the
great adam wainwright joining us for the
inning adam how you doing today
good how are y'all doing thanks for
having me we're great and say hello to
your buddy matt holliday on the
broadcast today
he's a regional
cable journalism journalist now huh hey
matt
hey adam what are you doing out of the
locker room how many deviled eggs have
you had
no i'm this is during the game matt i'm
i'm all focused i'm all cardinals
go team
also not much of a deviled eggs guy it's
got a it's got to have some smoked
barbecue on top of it or some barbecue
sauce
that's lifted by tyler o'neill and
vogelback is going to watch it
out of play o'neal bader and kisner
coming up in this frame okay adam let's
start with jack flaherty and what you've
seen from him so far this year and his
progression as an upper echelon pitcher
yeah well i think what we're seeing is
shades of 2019 um where he's working
down really well he's working up off of
that really well he's not hitting a lot
of that in between zone where he was
hitting a lot last year a lot of thigh
high stuff and holly can tell you you
know at this big league level if you're
living thigh high you're going to have a
hard time getting bigly hitters out so
he's doing great job of working down
that's his bread and butter and then off
of that working up in the zone getting
those lefties up and in
up across the top and then down and away
and down and in for chase he's he's
tough man when you're not and you're not
living in the middle of the plate
hitters are going to have a hard time
hitting you
adam at stan is the game of baseball
still as fun to you as it was 10 15
years ago
no it's much funner much more fun
in what way
i'd say
you know
i won't say more fun 10 years ago the
game was pretty fun i was pretty good at
this game 10 years ago that you know the
game's a lot more fun when you can
kind of do everything you're trying to
do out there accomplish
what you're trying to accomplish make
good pitches keep hitters off balance
and throw it hard enough to get it past
the bat every now and then but then uh
probably five four or five years ago the
game
the game stopped being fun
burns picks up the strikeout thanks adam
i appreciate the little pause there but
yeah no tell us about how things are fun
again for you though things have really
turned around and you're loving life and
kind of proven everyone wrong too right
yeah four or five years ago the game
stopped being fun because the game hurt
you know my body hurt everything hurt on
me especially my arm but my back hurt my
knees hurt my
arm definitely hurt you know there's a
very good chance i was pitching with a
literal broken bone in my elbow for over
a year
um and uh you know when you're when
you're having a hard time picking a fork
up it's it's a lot harder to pick up a
baseball and and cast it where you're
trying to throw it too with any kind of
authority so
glad to get over that hum there's a lot
of people that worked really hard to get
me back healthy again
our training staff was amazing our diet
our dietitian
really worked hard on me i had a bad
diet as matt can tell you matt and i
used to
basically share a room on the road we
would get room rooms next door and and
uh hang out all night playing video
games and and whatever and
playing cards and just talking baseball
and talking life
and uh man there was not a lot of good
good things going down this tube you
know it was a lot of a lot of junk a lot
of pizza a lot of late night stuff
drinking bad stuff not you know not a
i'm not talking about like hard alcohol
and stuff i'm just talking about like
cokes and lots of sugar drinks and that
kind of stuff and
um
just a lot you know i did change my diet
how to change my way of living how to
change my life how to change the way i
lifted the way i ran when i conditioned
and
and the way i pitched a little bit i
changed my arm slot you know when you're
when you're old you got to make
adjustments it's a game of adjustments
and if you don't you'll find yourself
sitting at home
so corbin so who is the uh who would you
adam who would you say is the better uh
mario kart player your skip schumacher i
think that's the question everyone wants
to know
no and no one really wants to know that
because everyone should know that i'm
the better player
[Laughter]
hey adam this guy pitching i'll just say
this this guy pitching is is uh
ridiculously nasty he i did not
appreciate he broke my record for for a
starting pitcher started the season with
uh
no walks and most strikeouts or whatever
it is and he's just blown it out of the
water but
you know he's just pitching he and the
guy yesterday woodruff they're just
throwing different stuff i mean the
pitchers nowadays are so talented and
such stuff he's working hard that cutter
heathrow i faced it earlier this year it
goes three different ways and it is
nasty nasty nasty and hard to hit
and he gets bader and sets a new record
52 strikeouts and no walks it's the most
case before issuing a walk
to start a season
he tops ken lee jansen's record of 51
set in 2017 and there you are he broke
your record as a starter
35
in 2013.
yeah and i'll just say you know
that year the what that streak ended
because i had to face a very tough
nationals team and uh bryce harper came
up in a really important part of the
game and i just
i didn't give in to him i mean
but i wouldn't have had 52 so either way
corbin's better
bravo corbin
and that's kisner finding some open
space for a base hit
fourth hit of the day for saint louis
they have a one-nothing lead burns has
three strikeouts and a new record to
start the season here's the swing and
miss that he produced off of harrison
bader well this is number 52 scott it
looks like a fastball all the way and it
just kind of disappears it has that late
cut action
very difficult pitch as adam was talking
about it looks so good and so inviting
and then right at the end it's just it's
gone out of the strike zone
earlier he had a he had a 3-2 count on
dylan carlson
and i looked over you know baseball is a
funny thing
like if you got a no-hit or going or
something you say man you know this
corbin burns got no hitter going or
whatever the next the next guy seems
like he gets a hit every time right and
so i look over at our trainer and i go
did you know he hasn't walked a guy all
season and then he threw a ball low but
that's the great thing about velocity
you know it it is uh
velocity it can make up for for mistakes
sometimes it can get you as you got to
chase a little bit out of the zone
sometimes i mean we saw
vogelbach who has an incredible idea
that strikes on yesterday chase the ball
over his head because
he's throwing 100 miles an hour so you
can get away with more stuff you get
more bad swings when you get that extra
velocity like burn says you know what
adam to ask your question though there
has to be a place in the game for guys
that do what you do what kyle hendricks
do that move the ball around change
speeds i know you're not the pitcher
that you were 10 years ago with your
stuff
but isn't there still room in the game
of baseball for the craft of pitching
and not just throwing
yeah oh absolutely yeah but i think it's
going to come back around honestly i
think you know right now there's kind of
a love affair with uh
with with many of the different like
spin rates and
exploring different areas of the zone
but you know at the end of the day no
pitcher should be happy about coming out
of the game after four or five innings
and uh
i think it'll come back around people
still you know it you see more pitchers
now coming up through the ranks that are
that are trying to learn how to pitch
again and not just throw well they're
looking up to you adam we appreciate the
time as always you're the man thank you
good luck the rest of the way right
we'll talk soon matt say bye
thank you guys thanks for having me
adam wainwright joining us mid second
cardinals up one nothing burns sets the
record
two around and nobody out lorenzo kane
is the runner at second base
swinging a fly ball hit well to center
vader drifting back onto the warning
track slips and falls still makes the
catch
kane is gonna head to third they're
gonna try and send him around here's the
relay throw home not in time
slipped the ball popped out and kane
scored another terrific performance from
brandon woodruff seven and two thirds
innings back-to-back games
in double-digit strikeouts for brandon
tyler o'neal go for two tonight
and o'neal lifts a high fly ball out
deep right it may go gone the game is
tied
tyler o'neal i think he's still thinking
about how did that ball get out the
tyler o'neill hit pablo reyes is the
runner over at first
shaw against helsley all for one
shaw to right center it's headed for the
gap it's down
travis shaw [ __ ] had double in the age
he was rocking and rolling a fly ball
left and deep get up
get up
[Applause]
last of the second with the cardinals up
one nothing time to introduce our first
poll question on the day of the day on
youtube and you can participate wherever
you're watching chime in and let us know
which picture could be on the sci young
highway early on in the season here and
we've given you a number of candidates
not named jacob degrom that's the name
of the game de grama on the injured list
right now he looked like the front
runner before hitting the il but which
nl starter not named degrom has the best
cy young chance between bauer flaherty
burns and max scherzer and as you're
voting you might get impacted by some of
the answers from our friends including
matt holiday matt you go first
you know what i'll take jack flaherty
just because that's who we're watching
and uh i've gotten to know him pretty
well i know what kind of competitor he
is
uh he's a he's a hard worker and kind of
a up-and-coming star in the game so i'll
go jack flaherty you know what i'm going
to double down on flaherty i just think
he has an abundance of talent we talked
about his only clunker of the year was
his first start of the year against the
cincinnati red since then he's been
about as good as you can get
6-0 and i think another thing that helps
him too matt he's playing on a good team
a winning team and i think he's going to
be a big part of where the cardinals are
going
and you know i think when you look at a
6-0 start i mean he's got a chance to
win a lot of games when you start out
with that uh 6-0 i know wins aren't
quite as important maybe in the metrics
uh these days but i still think when you
look at a chance to win 20 games i think
he's got a real shot
big time run support so far this season
for jack flaherty
and his offense backing them up in the
first inning
league leader in wins at the moment
2-0 to travis shaw gets a swing and a
miss that's a part of his game right
there i think we're just a big strong
guy but a 2-1 sinking fastball right
there
travis shaw getting the green light
there turns it loose
instead of that ball that's 95-96 we
talked about it in the open
he's he's kind of a throwback he pitches
down in the zone quite a bit
and shaw lifts one
into deep right there is carlson and he
lets it go off the wall can't time it up
and heading to second base is travis
shaw with a double dylan carlson trying
to line it up and couldn't find the
baseball well it could be difficult in
milwaukee at this time of the day with
that roof you can see there's shadows
and it's very difficult you can lose a
ball in that open roof
you go from sunlight to there's some
shade there
in the right field part of the area you
can see how dark it is right there you
can see he has no idea where the ball is
and he finally
tracks it right before it gets to the
wall
yeah it looked like he lost it i i would
have said off the bat that that's a home
run or an out pretty easily
just because how high it was but it
looks like you said he lost it there for
a second by the time he he uh refound it
it was it was too late and uh shaw ends
up on second with nobody out
officially ruled a double for travis
shaw he's been racking up doubles in
this series also leads the team in
homers and rbis
seventh two bagger of the season he's in
scoring position to start off the second
for milwaukee and now their hottest
hitter avasale garcia stepping up you
know scott there are some guys that are
just horses for courses it seemed like
when travis shaw puts on a brewers
uniform he just seems to hit right
nicknamed the mayor of ding dong city
you love that nick i do
i actually have one of his bobble heads
in my office the brewers pr department
sent me a bobble head on
travis shaw bobblehead day
thank you mike fasalo you like that
nickname matt
i do i like all a lot of nicknames but
that one is uh that's the first i've
heard of it maybe i uh i should hear
more about that dan's the number one
promoter
of that nickname and shaw getting the
job done
garcia trying to bring him in
flaherty's 1-0 home
and then chase downstairs
here it is again see how the shade is
right to the back of carlson right there
he's going from sunlight to dark
much like hitters at wrigley field
during a day game where you're going
from shadows to daylight or daylight to
shadows
this is an interesting situation where
you you wonder with a
guy like garcia who's kind of paid to
drive in runs will look to shorten up
and try to get him over with no outs and
and be okay with taking a ground ball to
second base
offense has been tough to find in the
early stages of these games in this
series this is the sixth matchup of the
season between these two teams
garcia takes a pitch wide
i think when you look at the brewers
offense in general uh near the bottom in
offense
these are the kind of situations where
you have to get this run in and whether
it takes manufacturing it by taking the
grounder to the right side and and
turning it over to the guy behind you
but i think in looking at some of the
stats the brewers offense
this is a very important run for them to
pick up
two and two
there's a little bit of that increased
velocity that matt was talking about on
the pregame
down in the zone 91 92 miles an hour
that he reaches back when he needs it on
a 2-1 count where avasal garcia is
pretty good idea he's swinging
elevates want to get up there 95 miles
an hour
that's what matt's talking about with
the offense under four runs a game 25th
in major league baseball this season but
they have some standout starters
some solid bullpen names excellent
defensive club
dan do you see a little bit of crossfire
do you think jack flaherty creates some
angle on right-hand hitters where he's
getting that forced seamer uh going from
right to left a little bit with that
kind of the angle and
the crossfire look no doubt about it
matt and it's a lower arm angle and it's
very difficult what it does too it gives
them a little movement it gives them a
little cut on that fastball on the
previous pitch to garcia he had a pretty
good swing on it but the ball is just
kind of moving away from the barrel of
the bat so not only is it 94.95
but it has a little cut action
got him garcia down on strikes first
punch out of the day for jack flaherty
and behind him out in center field is
harrison bader he is miked up all day
long on youtube harrison take it away
you got room you got room you got room
you got room you got rome
[Applause]
turns
that's the good stuff the inside access
on that play that double for dylan
carlson or for travis shaw dylan carlson
missing the baseball in right field and
the little words of encouragement from
harrison bader as omar narvaez fouls the
first pitch back from flaherty so matt
is that the kind of conversations that
would go on if you're out there a little
pick me up after that one
oh yeah you're always constantly talking
to your fellow outfielders and picking
each other up and talking about what's
going on what you see what the wind's
doing maybe what the shadows hey if a
ball comes in this area i may need you
to come over and get it if i lose sight
of it
the sun is always a factor and talking
to each other so constant communication
that just missed to narvaez
first at bat back off the injured list
and the brewers catcher has been strong
at the plate so far this year in his
starts he's hitting 385 three homers and
11 rbis he's hit safely in 17 of his 19
starts so far this season
he dealt with a little hammy issue
and
takes a tight pitch
two balls in australia
so dan that strikeout gives him a chance
to get out of this inning
a lot easier right i mean i i feel like
that when that strikeout right there
gives him confidence that if he gets
nevaez to ground out or fly out then
he's got a real real good opportunity to
get out of this inning with the pitcher
uh coming up
pretty soon to get out of this inning
without any runs boy just what aces do
talk about some big time pitching not at
bat to have a cell garcia it was almost
like jack flaherty took it up to another
level that cut fastball you see that
good hard slider right there to nevaeh's
but that's what the good ones do
they get into a little bit of pressure
and they're able to elevate the game
we've seen
flaherty's velocity 91-92 then he's
reached back the last two hitters at
94.95 whenever he needs it so he's
stepping it up a notch right here
full boat to nervias
bradley jr on deck shaw doubled to lead
off the bottom of the second for
milwaukee
garcia struck out
and narvaez filling up the count
cardinals got a run in the first thanks
to nolan aronado's rbi hit
carpenter followed with the knock arnado
was caught at home plate
popped up
[Applause]
arenado
finds it
jp how are the shadows and the sunshine
out in milwaukee this afternoon can you
see okay
well scott uh i really think that wind
played a huge role on that ball by shaw
to right field we're of course out here
in the outfield and the wind is at our
backs the wind is coming in so i've
often heard dan pleisak talk about how
wrigley field plays very differently
well when you've got panels open
roof open on a glorious day in milwaukee
and the wind is in pitcher friendly here
so far
yeah dan you know what it's like at
wrigley
it's a beautiful thing being on the
mountain about 4 15 4 30 in the
afternoon
very difficult to hit that ballpark
getting back watch his last play by nola
naruto not only is he great around the
back but old school the flip down shades
see he still has the shades up he picks
up the ball
then watch this
old school flips down the pop-down
shades
taylor made way to do it old-school
nolan aronado
i like that off yeah they used to have
those
they
they used to have those in the dugout
for everybody and then they've slowly
disappeared to where everybody has their
own oakleys but uh nolan is still
rocking it old school
hey matt why are those slowly going
extinct it looks like they're quite
practical
well i think the the oakley generation
and how uh how good-looking sunglasses
everybody makes now it seems to be that
uh everybody prefers the oakleys but
uh nolan likes the uh the oppo the
option to have your own eyes and then if
it gets in the sun you have the chance
to flip them down and use them so it's
like you said it is very practical but i
think there's some fashion flair that's
involved
we saw goldschmidt rocking the nikes
jackie braley doesn't like this call
right here this ball is off the plate a
couple inches off the plate and against
a guy like jack flaherty last thing you
want to do is
be behind him to count one two so many
multiple weapons for flaherty
if jack flaherty's getting that pitch
right there it's gonna be tough for
these hitters today because if he can
locate that pitch you're not gonna hit
that
jack's coming off seven scoreless
innings against the rockies on friday
and his first career home run
in that one
actually the best ovation
after the homer was from wainwright his
natural reaction was great
bradley jr to center
vader glides over
and that's gonna do it for the second so
shaw with the laid off double he's
stranded good work by jack flaherty
we'll get back to the st louis cardinals
in the third
yanks it down the left field line will
it stay fair it is hooking and it is
caught up against the wall what a catch
what a catch
justin williams
and he smokes it one-nothing cardinals
he almost broke the side and left field
you can hear that up here this is going
to go from questionable foul ball to
souvenir you're calling it yeah
way back
at the wall
my man called it he called it and we're
tied nolan has tied
[Applause]
are you calling it i'd like to see it
well everybody would like to see it i
want to know if you're calling it okay
why not
[Applause]
there's a swing and a high-fly ball it's
a deep left field flaherty has just hit
a home run
his first major league home run
[Applause]
it's one nothing cardinals top three a
unique viewing aspect of these games
that we love don't forget to check out
youtube's live game commentary featuring
mlb the cardinals the brewers and a
select group of youtube creators you can
view the live game commentary on your
computer your mobile device smart tv
we're keeping an eye on the discussion
throughout the broadcast we'll take some
of those questions actually a call out
to all of our creators right now
questions for brandon woodruff he's
going to join us after this happening
we'll mix some in during our interview
and also the unique polling that we have
live on youtube we have our first
question out there right now you can
check those out throughout the game
please participate and we'll get the
answers from dan and matt as well as we
continue along we have a few good ones
coming up today first one on the board
was which nl starter not named jacob
degrom has the best cy young chance
those results coming soon
it's tommy edmund to lead off the third
inning edmund carlson goldschmidt
edmonds scoring the only run of this
game so far that was actually the first
run of this series for st louis before
the eighth inning
corbin burns coming off a three
strikeout second four total in the game
corbin burns it's just easter cutter
machine and this is what it this is
bread butter it's amazing the
transformations made this is 97 miles an
hour so it's not like it's an 88 89 mile
an hour cutter as that holiday touched
on it's kind of a one-trick pony like
mariano rivera but he throws it on both
sides of the plate and he throws it with
incredible velocity and that's one of
the reasons why he's so difficult to
center and hit
the ball and two strikes to edmond
that's nasty well then he does this that
he takes him a little bit off but he has
it's almost a slurve not really a true
slider because it would be harder that
was 83 miles an hour so we get you
looking hard on that cutter down and in
and he follows it up you see the hand up
on top that's almost that curveball grip
that's a nasty pitch right here to tommy
edmond
so a lot of different weapons
the second time through the order he
went curveball change up curveball to
tommy edmond after he hit his cutter
into right field for a base hit to get
the first inning rally going so second
time through the order it looks like
he's going to use more off speed pitches
and he's going after another record
let's bring it back most strikeouts
between walks
cara cole this year that's an active
streak and kurt chilling back in 2002
burns two away from matching coal who
just pits last night a gem against the
tampa bay rays how about that 12
strikeouts no walks eight innings all of
a sudden things were really rocky in the
bronx
running was wondering what's going on
with the red sox are they going to win
the division the yankees are struggling
all of a sudden the pitching is stepped
up
taiwan walker was really good in this
last one corey kluber has been throwing
the ball great jordan montgomery
giacarlo stanton white hot right now all
of a sudden the yankees are hitting
they're pitching and
the noise is a little bit quiet in the
bronx now not as loud as it was a week
to 10 days ago a former team of matt
holidays yeah i mean the freakout factor
in new york sometimes can be high after
a short period of time matt
yeah i mean i think if you just look at
their roster and the talent that's on
the roster eventually you know if you
don't overreact especially in what we
have is a full-term long season uh you
know i think last year you could you
could overreact because it was such a
short season but i think when you look
at 162 uh you're talking about too much
talent to stay down too long
there you see brandon woodruff joining
us after this top three comes to a close
well it's a streak in the end right here
he's behind three balls and one strike
that was a pretty good pitch i think
corbin burns wanted that last one
carlson swings runner
that just goes to show you how good that
cutter is
you're sitting on it three balls in one
strike and you get it and you pretty
much get it middle middle and still
missing
that's part of the reason he's got this
streak is he's got that pitch he can
just throw that pitch pretty much down
the middle and guys have a hard time
hitting he's not afraid to challenge the
middle of the play
and matt that's what ken lee jansen did
especially in his prime burns breaks the
strikeout record without a walk to start
the season kenley had it back in 2014
and we're again talking about that money
pitch in the cutter
yeah i mean again you can just aim for
the middle it's not one of these guys
where he has to pick around the zone or
he has to try to be too fine when he
gets behind in the count he can rear
back and throw that cutter and just aim
for the middle which a lot of guys can't
get away with
and that's daniel vogelbach fairball
dylan carlson said it hit his foot
he's going to hang around and see if
that can you review that
nobody knows better than the hitter if
it hits your foot there's not very good
typically not very good actors hitters
and
if you don't run you typically does hit
your foot you don't you don't stand in
the box if it doesn't hit you yeah
there's no question that was right off
their goals
it was
right toe yo
yeah collected the ball as if it was
foul but
makes the throw over to burns
so two outs at the moment
[Music]
is he allowed to take his shoe off and
show him his toe
oh
carlson's gonna continue this at-bat
is this reviewable or is this not a
reviewable play
[Applause]
[Music]
checking on if it's reviewable for you
matt
craig council
still getting another word here in
well we reviewed it matt
and it looks like yes we did that we got
it
we got it right
like i said hitters are not very good
actors you can very much tell what
happened by the reaction of the hitter
[Music]
[Applause]
at-bat continues after the foul ball
this place might go nuts if the walk
record gets broke right here and no more
craig counsel for the rest of the game
as you saw him head to the tunnel
ejected from the contest here in the
third carlson sends one to left bradley
jr racing over to the line adjusts
on the move and makes the catch
had to redirect his route to retire
carlson two away i think correct
council's gonna go for the runway and
say well you know what he was arguing
for not you could clearly see this hits
right off of the top
of the right foot of dylan carlson
pretty obvious
even daniel vogelbach kind of gave up on
the play and was like hey maybe we gotta
free out here
you know it's interesting when john paul
was talking about the wind it looked
like it played jackie bradley pretty
much
had a hard time with that ball down the
left field line he almost overran it it
looks like the wind is a real factor out
in the outfield
and bradley jr gold glover in center
field one year with boston
goldschmidt
takes the pitch down the pike
that's basically what what's made burnt
so effective we've seen that cutter
96-97
takes a little bit off that's almost the
slider at 86 miles an hour so we've seen
the cutter the slider and we've also
seen the curveball
so he's just not a one-trick guy
goldschmidt lines that one up and sends
it to bradley jr and left
a two out base runner for st louis
back to craig council
being tossed from this game there it is
you see
all the way sneaking in on the right
side of your view
pat murphy's gonna take over the bench
coach who uh has done some head coaching
in his days and a little bit of interim
managing uh back with the san diego
padres go ahead matt
it looked like it took craig a while to
say the magic word but he finally got
there and
said
jim reynolds had had enough and now
he'll he'll stand slightly off the
probably off the dugout where nobody can
see him and help manage the rest of the
game but
maybe he'll turn it right over to pat
and just kind of let him go with it
pat was a great head coach at notre dame
and arizona state for council by the way
first time he was ejected
from a game this season
and the 19th time in his career you can
kind of see the game plan for noel
alvarado trying to jump at ambush early
had a base hit and at first at bat to
drive in that run running he's up there
swinging
you can definitely tell that he's
changing speeds more the second time
through he's mixed in the curveball and
the slider a little bit more and
maybe the two-seamer a little bit
lazy fly ball who wants it
finds it in the sun
and that sits down the saint louis
cardinals in the top half of the third
cardinals have a run on the board so far
today against corbin burns back to jack
flaherty in the bottom of the inning
kane back in there
last appeared in the contest on the 13th
of april swinging a high drive center
field wow welcome back lorenzo kane
that's a return
there's a base hit back up the middle
and duval around third on his way to the
plate kane's throw is close
and not again saying he got him
he is out all right there we go well
oscars
sends one in the ear right side foul
territory and tyrone taylor with a
sliding catch for out number one
1-0 pitch to house her and hauser sends
this one in the air deep right field
racing back as cooper at the track he
has done it again
adrian hauser goes deep
off of castano again adrian hauser
lightning strikes twice against castano
how sharp hater will be after sitting
for a week
lets it fly and a swing and a miss and
there you go
and there's strikeout number 400 fastest
in major league history josh hader
[Applause]
um
brewers half of the third trailing one
nothing here in milwaukee jack flaherty
getting ready to go against eight nine
and one for milwaukee which includes
corbin burns he's on deck and let's pay
off the first poll on youtube which nl
starter not named degrom is the best cy
young chance
burns
takes the pie 36 percent
as he beats jack flaherty's 29 mark
trevor bauer at 23 and max scherzer
checks in with 12
of the vote
we'll see that flaherty versus burns
matchup coming up
first it's louis cerius
and now time for our state farm dugout
interview as we welcome in our next
guest all-star brandon woodruff joining
us coming off a gem yesterday seven and
two thirds one run ten strikeouts woody
how you doing today
i'm doing good uh it's good to finally
see some warmer weather and the roof
open and
sun shining and uh you know this weekend
we're getting to 50 in the capacity so
everything's good we're loving it hey
you want to help us out we didn't
include you because we knew we were
going to have you on here for the poll
question you're obviously off to a
standout start but who's your vote out
of the four players that i mentioned for
the early cy young candidate aside from
jacob degrom
okay that's that's pretty easy for me
it's the guy on deck right here and he
can also hit too so
um
you know and hauser as well man he's put
he's been putting on the show me and me
and freddie are we're trying to pick up
the slack but i tell you what these guys
are
on the mount are good but uh i'm gonna
have to definitely go with corbin
with a knock to start off the brewers
portion of the third inning and burns
coming up
you know it you know what he you take a
lot of pride in actually get hitting
adrian hauser hit a big bomb the other
day how much time do you spend on that
spring training working on your craft in
the batter's box
i tell you what this year was a little
bit different um
just in terms of you know we were still
trying to wait out and see what was
going to happen with the dh and stuff
like that so
i think normally
we get started a little bit earlier but
honestly it mostly comes down to you
know most of the time we're doing what
corbin's
about to try to do right here is get a
bunt down and try to put a
runner in a scoring position he does get
the bunt down there it is
zach
muveres over to second so one in scoring
position with one out and back to the
top of the order in colton wong hey
brandon when you watch a guy like corbin
burns he's incorporated that cutter
is it is it a pitch that you've tinkered
around with at all because you see the
success that he's had with it
um you know what i've i've done a couple
different things i
breaking ball the two different breaking
balls for me right now have been
um
something i've been trying to do i go
back to double a 2016 and i feel like
last year i started to have a little
success with it in the shortened season
and then this offseason really you know
hammered those two out um i feel like
i've always been able to throw the two
different fastballs four seam two seam
and change up but the um
breaking balls have really come around
for you know for me last year and this
year so
um
but there are times where i do get on
the side of the fourth seam a little bit
and it does cut but i've never
intentionally tried to do it but just
seeing how
um you know corbin's ball plays so well
and he throws it extremely hard so and
it has a ton of movement but
i just think it's a it's one of those
things where his hand is consistently
gets in a good spot at release point and
that's something that um
i don't do as well so i try to stick to
what i know what works for me and um you
know go with that but corbin has worked
really really hard on um perfecting that
pitch and complimenting it and it's i
mean you see the results it's
unbelievable yeah he is so fun to watch
on the mound gets the job done with the
sac bunt as well and our youtube
creators have questions for you brandon
and you know where we're going they just
they can't resist so i'll do a
two-for-one here
okay here's one from giraffe neck mark
i'm going to give you two in a row
because they're relevant for each other
okay
being a pitcher that is such a good
hitter are you excited to be able to hit
again this year and then cowboy jeff
adds on how did it feel to homer off
kershaw i feel like i asked you this
every year but is this
that's fine that's fine um i'll tell you
it's
um i i love it personally i love it it's
it's really cool
you get some moments that you just don't
get with the with the dh and i
understand i see what people say about
the dh but that's what makes the
national league the national league and
a lot more strategy goes on with it and
man you just see like hauser hit i mean
he had a opposite field bomb in marlins
park and even for a hitter that doesn't
really happen so
he's got big pop i think it's
i love it i love getting in there and
getting to see these uh you know front
line guys and just really see how how
difficult it is and and
and it's just fun to be able to try to
help your calls and it keeps you in the
game a little bit longer if you can
handle the bat a little bit so
um but you know in the in the home run
you know a few years ago that was
it definitely changed the way pitchers
pitched me now uh i try to tell people
i'm not that great of a hitter i just i
look hitterish in the box but when
they're throwing the braking stuff man
and and these balls are coming in at you
know mid 90s that stuff's hard to hit so
um
and you just understand on the other
side of it when you're on the mound it's
just you just need to get up there and
attack and
uh you know make these guys beat you so
um definitely a cool moment for me and
that's something i'll you know always
you know have hey what was going through
your mind as you were rounding it
rounded the bases off of kershaw you get
the second rounding third do you even
know a handshake going to the third base
coach what's going through your mind
when i touch first base i don't remember
and this is the this is the honest truth
i really don't remember too much i
remember i touched the first base showed
some emotion there looking back on the
dugout and then after that it was
after that i don't remember too much
running around the bases i remember uh
coming back in and everybody just kind
of you know jumping on top of me mobbing
me hit me in the helmet and
and then very very quickly after that um
i'll never forget it curtis granderson
comes up to me
and thank goodness there was no outs and
he goes hey man he's like i know it's a
it's a huge moment but you got to go in
here and settle down you got to go pitch
again so
um thank goodness for curtis to do that
because i don't think i could have
gotten that heart rate slowed down if he
wouldn't have uh you know come up and
and told me that but i don't remember
too much about running around the bases
i just i have to you know i've seen the
video plenty of times and i remember
um
almost taking lorenzo's arm completely
off and we joke about it still we'll
watch it i mean i almost snap his arm in
half giving him a high five and he kind
of looks back at me like man i almost
almost took him out so
you got to be careful with that next
time
hey brandon when you were you talking
about the early season offensive
struggles that your team has had do you
guys as a staff kind of say hey you know
we got to take it upon ourselves to go
out and and pitch really well give our
our team a chance to win because the
offenses had a bit of a hard time
getting it going
you know i don't think i don't think we
really look at um
look at it that way i think we just try
to everybody tries to prepare and do
their job in between each start and then
when it's your start day you just go out
compete
and leave it on the field so i think we
just try to handle it that way and just
knowing that we've got a really good
team and the offense will come around
brandon this was fun thanks so much for
hanging with us all right yep keep
swinging thank you appreciate it
thank you that's brandon woodriff on a
global stage on youtube it's one nothing
cardinals after three flaherty looking
strong
fred bird doing a little fishing today
at big mac land has he forgotten all of
his animal instincts
that's not how he's supposed to catch it
that's a good point did i tell you about
the gift that fred bird gave me a couple
of years back no i
you didn't tell me i showed me well this
reminded me he showed me a nice sweater
is that right that's beautiful got a
little fredbirds on you know like the
christmas ones that have reindeer all
over it's like that but with fred birds
what will fred bird do today while he is
vacuuming the cardboard cutouts
he figured i guess i got to get my
chores done
last night it was the ironing board and
tonight fred bird is
bird watching he's a birder
who'd have thought it he's got something
new for us every game and tonight
apparently he is
back to school and
it looks like he is virtually learning
and yes that is fred bird and yes i do
believe that is
tiger king tiger king
very appropriate exotic that may be his
best one yet i think so
[Laughter]
[Music]
we've reached the fourth inning
carpenter o'neil and bader coming up for
the cardinals as we check out some stand
out deuce
in major league baseball look at the
flow from some of these superstars which
brings us
jazz chisholm he's added some red
streaks to that blue action julie girlie
l i mean there is so much action going
on up there josh hader with the long
locks corbin burns has that flow going
too as he's back on the mound today for
the first time in a couple weeks who has
the most unique hairstyle in baseball
right now stay on the board here with us
chisholm who we just showed you guys
we showed you tatis junior and john gant
recently rocking the cornrows too so
some really unique hairstyles dan and
i'll let you go first i'm gonna go with
yuli guriel every time that helmet comes
off i i kind of look at that and go wow
you know
it's very creative and it takes a i
guess you have to really be confident in
yourself to to go ahead and keep that
look and make that look your brand it's
like a tower it just it just keeps
growing on top yes it's like the gift
that just keeps on giving right little
chia pet action matt your selection
i'll go with jazz chisholm i don't know
that i could pull off the blue and you
said there's more colors added to it
he pulls it off pretty well he's got a
what the kids call a lot of swag going
um you know so i'll go with uh with jazz
and his uh multi-colored uh uh
you know whatever that style is
it's a great call i love it john gant
really going out there too i know
cardinals fans are digging it
we saw him work yesterday here's the one
one to carpenter it sells away
all right one more helper
wisconsin knows this guy well hey happy
days right
he's like why didn't you put me on the
pole
home of the happy days
brandon woodruff talked to us earlier
about some sunshine today in milwaukee
corbin burns moving the count to two and
two
there's cam oh he got rid of the
cornrows at least for now
i mean that's just so flexible he can do
so many things with that kind of nice
hair
it's just like the way that he works on
the mound he's versatile he can start
can pick things up in the middle innings
long relief high leverage
he's there
and burns spots that one beautifully
for the strikeout his sixth of the day
he just moves the ball in and out and
that one's 89 miles an hour we've seen
that cutter anywhere from 89 to 97 98.
kind of misses the target nevada's is
sitting away that's the change-up grip
89 mile an hour changes
up yeah
was intended to be away but that's tough
right that's that bring that greg maddox
brought that pitch into play started at
the lefty's hip and bring it back in
that's a tough you know change up right
at you that's a that's a tough pitch an
accidental very tough pitch
most powerful hitter of the series tyler
o'neil
homer in game one on tuesday
and another one yesterday six homers in
16 starts since coming back from the
injured list entering today
you know tyler
tyler o'neill is one of these guys that
if if he could just increase his his
swing and miss rate you know and make a
little bit more contact i think he has
uh the power potential and the speed and
the ability to be an elite offensive
player he's just a little bit too
swinging too much swing and miss for me
right now
he crushes the baseball when he connects
looking more locked in since his return
from the il who's dealing with a groin
injury but
elite runner
strong guy
gold glover last year in left field
[Applause]
you almost feel as if if you're a hitter
you get a count leverage there two balls
in one strike
you're a deal
you put yourself in a tough spot right
now 2-2 we've seen
burns able to throw the curveball for a
strike on a strikeout we've seen the
slider that cutter
you just know that something's breaking
away from you
it's a video game which button are you
practicing this this is a tough one
[Applause]
well one of the things with corbin burns
that's his 55th strikeout of the year
with no walks there it is that's the
curveball
so we've seen a lot of cutters this
afternoon an occasional slider and
he just seems like he's pulling the
string at the right time
shadows are starting to creep in a
little bit now you can see it almost
into that left-handed batter's box so
it's going to get a little bit more
difficult for both of these teams to try
to put something together we've seen
this this has lived up to the billing so
far jack flaherty has been terrific
pitched out of trouble a couple of
occasions
corbin burns gave up a run in the first
thing but he's been rock solid ever
since 56 strikeouts without a walk
matching the current record held by
garrett cole and curt schilling that's
an easy one two three in the fourth to
sit down the side in order
as we head to break we take a closer
look at jack flaherty in this mlbpa
infield chatter feature watch this
i don't think about where i'd be without
her i just think about how thankful i am
to be in the situation i am because of
her how do you feel about me being home
right now
well
she means everything to me she's
superwoman wonder woman whatever you
want to call her when jack flaherty was
three weeks old he was adopted by a
single mom who became the single biggest
influence for jack and his brother
eileen flaherty's life lessons continue
to shape jack today this cool thing to
be myself to trust myself and to always
remember it's never about me
and that was that was the thing that
just was within the house you know we
won't tell people that we don't have any
trophies out at the house where is it
located right now it's in the attic at
home he's just jack because that's how
eileen raised him i go over their house
on on wednesdays and i do yoga
and you know when i'm done with yoga
that's trash day when he's at work
flaherty is all business when he's not
he's often quietly giving back in st
louis always preferring no one knows
about it she did her the best that she
could and i think she did a pretty damn
good job and uh yeah she's just done a
lot she's she's been everything
[Music]
[Applause]
we're in the home fourth cardinals up a
run and each week this season we will
focus on a youtube content creator
featured in our live game commentary
section today our creator spotlight
shines on finn mcconnell on finn's
channel you can see and hear him provide
live commentary on a variety of sports
video games such as mlb the show madden
and much more the name is the finn
ftw for the win the finn for the win 129
000 subscribers his videos have over 35
million views and every day just about
he uploads a video one o'clock eastern
three o'clock eastern does a lot of
talking to himself to entertain the
crowd and the people and the thin ftw
say hello to us in the live chat and
welcome aboard today thanks for watching
with us and thanks to all the creators
for hanging for a pitching duel as
expected between jack flaherty and
corbin burns okay so as daniel vogelback
steps in for his second at-bat of the
day what kind of adjustments matt can
the brewers make second time around here
against the cardinals ace
well it looks to me like he's working
out out down and away corner like we
talked about um they're gonna have to
use the whole field uh to try to make
anything happen and like dan said the
shadows are gonna get worse as the game
gets going and and you're gonna start
talking about be tough to pick up spin i
think you'll see pitchers start to throw
more breaking balls as that shadow
starts creeping closer and closer to the
pitcher and and these bullpens both bull
pins have you know nasty stuff waiting
for these hitters so i think it's going
to get harder as the game goes on to to
to score something off these guys and
one note josh hader not available today
he's pitched in four of the last five
days from milwaukee including
back-to-back outings they made him work
yesterday to pick up the uh save for
milwaukee
well that's one of the things that
council brewers have had the last couple
of seasons depth into bullpen devon
williams last year was the most
devastating reliever of the game how
about daniel vogelbach
yanks that one foul a lot of different
options and correct council came out a
couple of years ago talking about his
bullpen guys that he had a collection of
out getters and it's a collection of
guys that are ready to go from the sixth
heading on and
they're taking a look at josh hader has
been just terrific since he's put on a
brewers uniform
kind of a hard guy to pick up good upper
mid 90s fastball he's incorporating the
slider a little bit a little bit more
into his repertoire and
was able to fight through that game last
night so one of the things the brewers
feel like if they have the lead
going into the sixth and seventh inning
they feel pretty good about it
ball four
a free pass for vogelback to start off
the brewers fourth and let's bring in jp
at the ballpark as jp the ballpark is
going to get louder as we continue along
over the next few weeks
and scott i love it i remember coming
here last year for an mlb game of the
week on youtube but i had none of my
friends here no fans but now
50
crowd this weekend will be available and
then the brewers announced today scott
100
on june the 25th one of the very best
atmospheres in all the baseball and the
city that loves their brewers so much
scott it's just so great to hear the
story here and all around the major
leagues more and more fans safely in the
ballpark that's great news we love to
hear it and we know capacity has been
increasing over in saint louis as well
here's travis shaw who doubled in the
second off of flaherty
i'm sure the players are thrilled that
the fans are starting to come back
they're going to start to play in front
of bigger and bigger
crowds and and i just can't imagine last
year i don't know about you dan but i
relied heavily on on the crowds
especially as you get later in the
season to kind of give you that extra
adrenaline on those days when you feel a
little fatigued and i think that
especially markets like st louis and new
york especially you having played for
both teams there's just a there's a buzz
there's there's some there's something
at yankee stadium that they're just
uplifting you go to a game there and
that place is rocking and rolling the
days that you're tired that kind of
momentum just kind of gets you going
and i think a lot of players miss that i
thought one thing last year you had to
really be a self-starter you had to be
able to motivate yourself and i couldn't
imagine that grind of being an everyday
player day game after a night game
not having that energize that fan and
the music and everything to get you
fired up so i think the players are
loving this right now that they're
starting to get more and more fans back
into these ballparks
i think even me as a spectator watching
it on tv it almost felt like you were
watching
a spring training scrimmage when last
year when you tuned into a game and
there was nobody sitting behind home
plate and the foul balls you'd see and
there'd be tarps and you'd see you know
nobody sitting there in the ball just
kind of laying there
it's just a much better visual watch i
think on tv as well
it feels so much more normal this year
as shaw sends one to center racing in
his bader and he's called off and the
catch is made there in shallow center
field by tommy edmond nice play to run
that one down for out number one
[Music]
[Applause]
travis shaw had visions of going two for
two on a couple of soft hit balls get
that fly ball
that was lost in this one here this is a
terrific play
not an easy play going out by tommy
edmond there harrison bader sliding in
hope luckily they avoid a collision
heads up play
yeah that's what they teach the out the
the the outfielder goes low and the
infielder goes high so that you don't
run head to head into each other and
there's no serious injuries so you hope
that that uh you know he slides there
and if at worst case it kind of takes
his legs out but nobody gets hurt so a
good good play by bader to kind of go
low and and a good catch by edmond as we
talk about he's he's very versatile in
where you can play him edmond making his
first start at shortstop this season
that's driven to deep center bader's got
it this time for a long loud fly ball
out number two off the bat of avicell
garcia
i think the win is a real factor today
guys i mean i these are balls that i i
think are playing there that these are
typical home runs and even the reaction
of the hitters it looks like they feel
like uh they got these pretty good and
in a very offensive ballpark most of the
time it looks like the wind really is
kind of blowing in and keeping some of
these balls in the ballpark
it's about 10 miles an hour a little
left to right action going on hey matt i
know it's probably annoying for you and
for your fellow outfielders but for us
it's a fun watch to see the route
circling around and every fly ball
is a little entertaining a little more
entertaining as we
roll it back to bader's adventure in
center
well
like you said
it looked like you know he he thought
that they had a chance to get out but
you know it's it's a good ten feet short
and uh you know
right there it looked like he maybe he
just missed it a little frustrated that
he caught it off the end a little bit
but
i've seen this park play really small
and when the roof's closed and the
panels are closed it's very hitter
friendly
there's your wind in milwaukee today
shadows working for flaherty
just missed down
that's the spray chart for omar narvaez
last 100 batted balls 200 feet or less
of course mostly gonna pull that
baseball
a down 20 20 at the plate after a strong
2019 and the hitting prowess is back
four pitch walk
two on
and two outs here in the fourth
looks like jack lost his concentration a
little bit right there a four-pitch walk
for a guy with his command is is pretty
uncommon so he'll have to dial it back
in but as you continue to see the shadow
it keeps moving closer and closer to the
pitcher
which makes it more and more difficult
for these hitters to pick up spin
and a chat on the mounds as jackie
bradley jr
will crawl in
with two on bogle back at second norvaez
on first two walks for flaherty in this
fourth
i think the brewers felt very fortunate
this offseason the free agent market was
slow and a guy like jackie bradley jr
kind of fell right into the brewers
wheelhouse
and a lot of people around milwaukee
were wondering where he was going to
play with christian yelich on the
injured list heading out for assignment
in the minor leagues this weekend
it's a little bit of a crowded outfield
with lorenzo kane avacyl garcia
that things have a funny way of working
on he's a winning player
craig council told us before the game
one of the reasons why they think their
offense run production is better than
it's been
since he's been managing a good
defensive ball club they struggled to
hit but there are a lot of teams that
have scuffled offensively this year but
the brewers their starting pitching has
been good the back end of the bullpen
rock solid and eventually jackie bradley
coming into play hitting 171. he's
eventually going to hit for the brewers
but he gets a little bit more consistent
playing time at some abs
you know it makes you wonder when when
yelich comes back healthy uh what
they're gonna do with those four guys if
potentially one of them could slide over
to get some at bats at first base um
even at looking at a guy like yelich if
he's having back problems if you could
take some of the stress off of him by
teaching him to play first and
and trying to get all four of these guys
in the lineup when he gets back healthy
bradley jr watches ball two
it's interesting to see the transition
for the brewers
with an emphasis on defense and mike
mistakas played some second base for
this team now they have best defensive
second baseman
in the game in colton wong
[Applause]
that's fouled back by bradley jr four
highest-paid players on the team are all
outfielders as well hey it makes sense
it's a fly ball world these days and
they have guys that know how to run it
down yeah there's been a lot of things
have been positive so far for the start
for the brewers one thing on the
negative casting hera who made the
position change when they signed colt
wong to first base they were hoping this
was a guy former first round draft pick
out of cal berkeley bat the ball skills
off the charts and he's hit at every
stop off to a slow start he's in the
minor leagues right now but i think uh
long term they're hoping that casting
hero that back comes back into play and
i think you'll be seeing him playing
majority of the first base post all-star
break if he can get things turned around
you know it's been a surprise to me to
see kesten hero struggle with the bat
my initial in watching watching him
swing the bat i i he's got a really good
swing uh sneaky pop for for a smaller
stature guy he can hit the ball out to
right center so i've been a little
surprised with with the fact that he had
to go back down to the minor leagues to
try to get things tightened up i really
see kind of a future
uh big time hitter and what he does at
the plate
i know one thing triple a nashville this
weekend is going to be hopping christian
yelich and castin here in the lineup
that's fun for the sound fans
flaherty to bradley jr up the middle and
they have a man there it's edmond
easy does it with the toss over to first
and that's gonna retire this side still
just one on the board it's st louis in
the first scoring to make it one nothing
we're completed through four
welcome to busch stadium a park not
designed for the power pack milwaukee
brewers but ideal for the st louis
cardinals this marks the cardinals 13th
world series in contrast to the brewers
who in their 13-year history are here
for the first time
and now for game one
and it's six to nothing milwaukee on a
blue double
cooper makes the play that's the ball
game 10 to nothing milwaukee over the st
louis cardinals
beautiful bush stadium another capacity
crowd here as we get ready for game
[Applause]
[Music]
and as two cardinals take the lead five
to four
scooter out of the stretch and a drive
with straight away shredder and willie
mcgee puts it away
a game of peace
[Music]
cardinals won brewers nothing so far as
we've reached the fifth and new to the
mlb game of the week live on youtube
this year the youtube player of the game
fans watching on mobile devices and
computers you can vote for which player
will receive the trophy during the
post-game show so you're essentially
also voting for our post game interview
conversation stay tuned we'll have the
player of the game polling options later
in the show
quite a few early candidates here
of course nolan arenado who's knocked in
the only run and then both starting
pitchers have been sensational all right
let's pay off our next youtube poll who
has the most unique hairstyle in
baseball right now i know
matt went with jazz chisholm
and dan you went with julie guriel but
guess who wins fernando tatis jr also
can bring it his hair game is strong
well there's some strong hair right
there too he lost both yes right
that we're missing the boat when it's
coming
yeah well i'm not much qualified to talk
about it
couldn't convince the crowd and there's
john gant we showed you our other option
with the long locks
it's kissner flaherty and edmund do up
for saint louis here in the fifth
so we'll start with kisner and i think
matt holliday is one of the only humans
on the planet that can call out yadi
molina and say hey yadi it would have
been cool if you played today for your
boy
as yachty takes a seat which he doesn't
do often matt
yeah i think he got a tip that i was
going to be doing this game and you know
decided that he'd rather listen in the
clubhouse and and really hear what i
have to say
than be out on the field and
so i really appreciate him you know
taking some time to sit in the clubhouse
and really focus on what i'm saying and
maybe pick up a few things pick up a few
tips here there well you know yachty
he's such a teacher he's going to text
you after the game and say okay i like
your cadence in the third inning
you don't shake yachty either this
kisner fouls that one back a ball and
two strikes corbin burns continues to
deal this afternoon scott braun matt
holliday dan pleisek hello matt you see
me up there
i see you guys here i am
yep in oklahoma i wish i was there with
you guys we miss you dan pleisek and
myself stationed in new jersey and jp
morosi out at the ballpark baseball in
2021. boy this matchup has been as
advertised corbett birds has yet still
to walk a batter seven punch outs on the
day so far this day
and he's throwing the ball as well as
he's thought it all year he's been about
as good as it gets right now in baseball
he's a tough at bat i mean as a
right-hand hitter when i'm watching this
and the way he's able to
throw the cutter away and then chase it
with a slower slider and then mix in the
breaking ball and i haven't seen a ton
of sinkers which i was kind of
interested to see how much he would use
the ball running the other way
i think he got goldschmidt his first
at-bat running one in on his hands but
it'll be interesting to see as we go
through the third time through coming up
if he starts to make the ball move the
other direction a little bit
good battle here for kisner and he loses
out on it to corbin burns strikeout
number eight of the afternoon we're only
in the fifth
get a good look at it here that's that
offset fastball 94 miles an hour with a
cut action
what makes it so lethal he throws it to
both sides of the plate
jp what do you think of this brewers
pitching staff
scott it's a huge reason why the brewers
have made the postseason in three
consecutive years the first time ever
for the franchise and would you believe
that one of the most important places
for their development is the pitching
lab at their spring training home in
arizona the research and development
department for the brewers has been key
in integrating the analytics with the
feel of pitching chris hook their
pitching coach here one of the best in
the game corbin burns brandon woodruff
devin williams with that dynamic change
up all of them can trace some of the key
adjustments they have made to their
pitching lab in phoenix and scott the
rap soto technology that they have at
every single minor league affiliate and
here at american family field as well
they've done such an incredible job with
their pitching staff and we've seen
some of their young arms really develop
into stars like the man that we're
watching this afternoon who currently
holds the record for most strikeouts
between walks but it's an active race
because garrett cole has a number at 56
in a row he pitched yesterday so burns
passes him for now then cole might top
him later this week
and he puts away flowers here comes a
tie
yeah
[Music]
yeah jack flaherty that's not a good
matchup for him this is uh
that's not a good matchup for a pitcher
hitting
almost the identical pitch
that he struck kinsler out on that hard
cutter nine down and away
he's throwing enough pitches in the
middle of the outer part of the strike
zone that you just can't go up there
looking in one particular area
tommy edmonds
struck him out the last time but
and at a bat he's not afraid to start
that backdoor slider start that hard
cutter and bring it off the plate back
around the outside corner so he's thrown
this cutter
to both sides of the plate that's what
makes it nearly impossible to hit
there's the back door action on the
slider
[Applause]
yeah
you know dan it's it's interesting he
works off the first base side of the
rubber for him to be able to make that
cutter go back door to lefties or front
door to righties uh from that side of of
of the rubber is pretty uncommon i mean
i you could talk about that a little bit
about where you place your foot on the
rubber but that's that's pretty amazing
that he can make that cutter work on on
the third base side of the plate you
know when you've talked to brandon
woodruff he was saying just how he's
able to get his hand at the right
placement and i think that's a lot of
what it has to do with matt it's an
uncomfortable angle you see where he's
standing more towards the first base
side you almost have to cut that thing
on the outside part of the plate to get
it there
but he's found the groove and pitching
is so much touch and feel and right now
he's really in that lockdown mode he's
run a couple of three ball counts so far
this afternoon but he's been at will
been able to throw that cutter
particularly down and into lefties when
he's needed to get a strike that's
pretty much been his his saving spot
be interesting to see 3-1 count right
here how aggressive edmund is
if he's uh if he's aggressive knowing
that he's going to be aiming for the
middle and and try to maybe jump ship
you know if you get that cutter coming
into a lefty get the bat head out he has
a chance with his kind of power to look
to maybe do some damage right here
edmond started the first
with a single
only man to score today and he's on
board again
reaches for a second time and the streak
has come to a close
corbin burns has finally issued a free
pass for the first time this season
that's pretty incredible gig is standing
ovation from the fans in milwaukee and
what a terrific start to the year for
corbin burns
3-1 pitch that very easily could have
been called a strike too the high strike
has been really in play in baseball the
last couple of seasons just curious
right now how long the brewer's gonna go
with him he's missed almost two weeks of
inactivity
so it'll be interesting to see there's a
lot more fish to fry he's at 74 pitches
i'm not sure where they feel comfortable
with but this pitch is it is out of the
zone but awfully close
yeah i mean i think if it's obviously
tommy edmonds not the tallest guy i
think in a a little bit taller of a
player it's a strike but you know when
you're dealing with a littler guy that
the ball is definitely up i think this
is probably his last inning uh dan i
would say that you know they might give
him a chance to get through this inning
but uh i would say this is probably it
so they're looking at four innings of
relief
yeah really the strength of this brewers
team has been the starting pitching has
been so good freddie peralta has been
terrific
brandon woodruff adrian hauser
it's really been a strong start to the
year and i think top to bottom the
brewers feel like they're starting
pitching is as good as anybody in the
national league not in including the
cardinals or anybody in the anal central
yeah it's hard to argue that for sure
nasty starters i mean it's it's guys
featuring some nasty stuff too i mean
it's it's sustainable in my mind
there's the brewers rotation ranked in
major league baseball number six in era
fourth in k per nine strikeout to walk
ratio
thanks to guys like
burns peralta woodruff
that one sails away
it's dylan carlson who's over two so far
and remember tommy edmond also stole
second base back in the first off of
norvaez
i think this is a good opportunity to
try to steal a base again i would look
for tommy edmond to potentially
look to get getting scoring position
right here and and uh and try to steal
another base
and and and help the cardinals you know
scratch off another win another another
run in in a day where it's getting
tougher and tougher to see to try to get
one more insurance round
he's going to keep him tight to the back
what's unique about burns is that he had
to miss these two weeks and couldn't
make a rehab outing otherwise they would
have had to push him back
even further they wanted him back on a
big league hill as soon as possible so
here he is with the runner going and
there's the throw it's high and
another stolen bag for tommy edmond his
seventh of the season and third of the
series well really stole the base has
been a difference in the game
tommy edmunds with the lead off single
the first
able to get into scoring position here's
a big stolen bag two with two outs
nevaya has really no chance to throw him
out
it's a big jump off of corbin burns and
even if that throw was on the money they
had no chance of getting tommy edmond
there
good job of getting his hand back on the
base that's a big play holding the tag
on the runner these days just trying to
pop up and just barely coming off a lot
of runners have a hard time holding that
base carlson ships one to center in
comes kane he's got it
and corbin burns does complete the fifth
but
he finally walked someone it was bound
to happen eventually what a day from
both men on the mound
county stadium milwaukee the scene for
game three of the 1982 world series in
the fifth inning of this scoreless time
get high and deep to right field and
it's gone home run willie mcgee
and the cardinals jump in front three to
nothing
[Applause]
that's two for mcgee another homer
the cardinals
we go to the bottom of the seventh
inning five to one saint louis
base hit right field one run is in two
runs are in five four
and they are wild in milwaukee
a 7-5 final score and all even at two
games apiece
here to game five
molitor gets one out there double play
the right center charlie moore
what an outstanding play
well hit right field home run
[Applause]
left field this could be it the
milwaukee brewers take a one-game lead
as we'll go back to saint louis
[Music]
welcome back to milwaukee there is no
player more closely associated with the
brewers recent renaissance than
christian yellows the back to back
batting titles the 2018 mvp
signed the mega extension last march but
then a difficult 2020 season and
injuries this year two different stints
on the injured list with lower back
issues he has played in one
major league regular season game in the
last month scott but there is some
optimism that has the fans returned here
to american family field that their mvp
christian yelich could be back on the
active roster before the end of this
month yeah jp they miss him in so many
ways
but the offense for milwaukee is the one
spot where they really have pinpointed a
need and christian yelich is one of the
best in the business when he's healthy
in that category it's eight nine and one
coming up for milwaukee urias swings out
of his shoes against flaherty on pitch
number 70 of the day from the cardinal
starter
who is staked to a one-nothing lead you
know greg council told this told us this
before the game that maria says it been
much easier it's been easier for him to
get the ball here to hit for a little
bit more power
they thought last year he was just kind
of put the ball in play guy but they
really think eventually he's going to
hit and he's going to hit for a little
bit of power he was trying to send the
ball to st louis just now
and an off-speed pitch from flaherty
another swing and a miss
right now if you're a hitter you're
you're begging for about about 15-20
more minutes of daytime but that shade
will be covering the mound and it won't
be as difficult to hit it's certainly a
little bit easier now than it was about
15 or 20 minutes ago when that shade was
halfway that line that shade line was
halfway between the mound at home plate
got him
inside corner paint
there's the call from todd tischner and
arias is down on strikes
pretty good pitch right here fastball in
after a series of stuff away a couple of
breaking balls
locks urias up on the inside corner
nice job by kenzer there of kind of
making that pitch look like it caught
that inside corner when when you look at
the box it looks like it's off i mean
that's a that's a tough pitch as a as a
right hand hitter when he's throwing so
many kind of those cut fastballs away
and the slider off of it for him to be
able to paint inside and get kid a
couple inches off the inside corner
that's a tough at bat
now pinch hitter and billy mckinney
three homers on the season
had a big spring with the ball club to
make the team
had a big catch too on a road trip in
san diego
if you're watching it all
would have been a basis clearing extra
base hit down the line in san diego and
right field made a fully extended great
catch
corbin burns officially done for the day
five innings on 78 pitches five hits a
run nine strike cats
one walk
and yeah you notice the
pitch count a little lower than
anticipated but he hasn't pitched in
about two weeks
you know guys going back to christian
yelich i i just don't think you can
understate how important he is to their
offense into this team of having that
mvp caliber player in the middle of your
order that you can rely on uh to to come
up with those big hits and then you know
sometimes teams will pitch around them
but it also provides you base runners
and opportunities to score and it looks
to me like just watching the brewers
it's
scoring is gonna be pretty difficult if
if those guys in the middle of the order
don't get hot lorenzo kane and some of
these veterans that they're they're
paying to to provide some offense
get it going so i just think that yelich
is such a huge part of getting this
brewers team into the postseason with
with the quality of pitching they have
christian with just two games played
since the 11th of
[Applause]
april yeah it's a 2018 mvp and then
last year in a shortened season he said
it himself that he was all around
terrible biggest slugging percentage
decline
in the game is on base plus slugging
percentage dropped over 300 points again
though small sample size
was trying to find himself timing-wise
and that's ship to center it's gonna
fall for a base hit
billy mckinney a pinch hit single with
one out in the fifth back to the top of
the order for milwaukee colton wong is
miked up today
my whole my whole process right now is
looking away i'm trying to hit him that
way
you know what if i see spin maybe i'll
clip mine in front
oh good fish
different at different speeds different
brakes
fastball man it gets on you yeah
because it starts slowing and it has
like a little at the end yeah
oh that's the good stuff matt colton
wong always talking baseball he's a
gamer and giving us some in-game
analysis
as that's pulled towards the right side
cardinals going to try and turn two not
just the one
as the four-stat is at second to erase
mckinney and wang replaces him at first
you know i think it just goes back to
talking about jack flaherty where you're
talking about a guy that throws 50
four-seam fastballs and his spin rate's
not overly uh high for a major league
average pitch and and how he's able to
pitch uh with a 50 fastball rate that uh
there must be something else to it and
as he's talking about it has just like
that extra carry and a little bit of
that extra zip to it that throws hitters
off a little bit so interesting to hear
a guy who's facing him in real time talk
about what maybe makes this uh this
fastball so effective and and how he's
getting guys out uh using you know one
pitch for 50 of his pitches
i think many kids watching at home
worldwide on youtube dan are thinking
how do i do that can i give my fastball
extra life like jack no i think it's a
gift it really is if you'll hear and
matt will touch on this too there are
some guys matt that you've probably
faced that that have a heavy ball a
sinking fastball it's hard if you don't
have that it's just a natural gift and
there are some pictures that their ball
has tremendous carry
when i watch jack flaherty he reminds me
of a guy with the philadelphia phillies
and zach wheeler who they pitch down in
the zone
but the ball has that extra bit of life
it's 94.95 but the hitters take swings
at it's like it's 97 to 100 miles an
hour
and jack flaherty has that a colt wong
touchdown on that piece that his ball
just has that extra zip it gets on you i
think part of it too matt is he has a
real smooth delivery that kind of loads
you to sleep and then the ball it just
jumps on you at the end
it looks like he gets really good
extension like threw his fingers out in
front that that maybe uh you know adds a
little bit of life to it you know really
good reach you know he's a big strong
guy it looks it looks to me like he gets
it's good
uh distance he gets he gets out there
out front of the ball and kind of gets
on you a little bit more than the guys
that kind of retreat or maybe move
off to the side of the mound on their
finish
here's a good look what matt was talking
about the extension watch the reach that
he gets after he lets this ball go you
see the the front foot down and his
backhand almost coming across and
hitting his left pocket full extension
matt just like mike schill told us that
velocity is picking up
that's pretty nice weapon to have dan
when you can reach back and get your
best fastball of the game at pitch 84
and and i think that that speaks to the
conditioning and taking care of his body
and just kind of the overall
weight program and running program that
jack flaherty does to where you know
you're still in the 80s pitches 80
pitches and you're throwing your hardest
pitches that was 97 miles an hour go
back to the second inning travis shaw
started hitting with the lead off double
and then abbas salgueira we of iselle
garcia we saw the velo climbing that
last pitch was the fastest he's thrown
all afternoon at 97. so it's in there
there's gas left in the tank he's one of
the best condition pitchers in all of
baseball batting average against the
four-seam fastball he's fourth best in
baseball see what he dials up for
lorenzo kane with wong on first and
we'll do it again
97.
yeah he's going to get it right here how
comfortable he is throwing the breaking
ball but if you're lenzo cain and you're
selling out there on 97. jack flaherty
can throw anything close to the strike
zone with that hard breaking ball that
we've seen it'd be really tough for
lorenzo kane to make contact
oh come on
shook to the fastball shook to the
fastballs will be interesting
challenged kane again
and he fought it off
you see the pitch usage just what we
touched on in the pregame show 49
percent
four-seat fastball look at that
opponent's average so it's it's easy to
throw the number one when you
see the results
it's pretty amazing that he's is a
starter that he can get away with you
know being primarily a two pitch pitcher
at 80 percent for seymour slider
he's feeling the heat right now
[Applause]
dan as he throws more and more stressful
pitches here does that make you as i
guess as a pitching coach think about
you know hey we better get somebody
loose he's throwing a lot of he's
expending a lot of energy here in the
fifth inning with 88 pitches and he's
having to use his a fastball
over and over here to get out of this
inning yeah it does matt it's pitch
count he's about to throw his
89th pitch just looks like it's going to
be a slider down and away after about
four fastballs a row in the upper 90s
there it is
it's right down broadway different
speeds and jack flaherty gets the job
done with the strikeout two in this
inning five in the game five scoreless
and now the big bats for st louis coming
up in the sixth goldschmidt arenado and
carpenter
[Applause]
[Music]
bush stadium in saint louis game six the
milwaukee brewers are just one game away
from the championship mcgee is on it
first tommy hurries about it
[Applause]
here is daryl porter one ball one strike
and a high drive deep right
[Applause]
[Applause]
they are ready here in st louis for game
seven now it culminates into one game
for baseball's championship we're in the
bottom of the sixth inning of the final
game of this 82 world series
[Applause]
the whole city of saint louis
collectively holding his breath three
and two to count to gorman thomas
and that's the winner
that's the winner
a world series winner for the cardinals
[Applause]
so
why does jd martinez love bubble gum so
much and what is that watch on his wrist
find out on the season premiere of big
league lockers on youtube.com
mlb
milwaukee is the spot this afternoon if
you're looking for good pitching corbin
burns done for the day after five
innings and drew rasmussen is going to
take over for milwaukee cardinals have a
run it came back in the first their lead
off man tommy edmond with a single he
eventually scored that's the only run
scoring action that we've seen so far
today and here's rasmussen getting ready
to go to pitch the sixth yeah the right
hand run to year you look at the era
just a little south of five he's going
to probably be asked to go multiple
innings last night the brewers
when that one late last night that we
touched on craig counsel that josh hader
not available this afternoon he had
pitched four out of five days so
bullpen gonna have to shake things up a
little bit gets the blank five really
good innings from
corbin burns after missing nearly two
weeks
goldschmidt arenado and carpenter do up
this inning for st louis rasmussen last
pitched on sunday at miami picked up his
first save of his professional career
with an inning and walking a strikeout
you know it's so exciting getting the
starter out of there to have a guy come
in throwing the high 90s with an 87 mile
an hour slider
you know it's uh
it never ends that nowadays these guys
come in throwing uh high-end stuff so
just because the starters out of the
game is a hitter it doesn't mean the
bats get any easier
there's 96 up in the zone
and he's been on a roll lately as you
see arenado waiting
rasmussen's last nine appearances eras
079
a hit for goldschmidt last time up in
the third
and he works the count full pretty good
take right there on a two-two slider
that was down and away great take
pitch for four that 98 great take right
there
great take right there now he set
himself up to maybe get a fastball here
in a 3-2 count and and
potentially do some damage
ball four
goldschmidt's gonna lead off the inning
with a walk
to set up for nolan aronado
who pulled a base hit
in the first inning that scored tommy
edmond
and this is the
pull hitting damage pull side 25 times
out of these 39 hits this season so
second most in baseball that's just a
good old-fashioned pull power matt
yeah you know he's a he's got a very
direct swing so he he's very direct to
the ball uh he's he's out in front his
barrel gets out in front of his body uh
pretty easily so i'd like to see a few
more hits to the right side i think he
can do that i think that that's the best
version of nolan aronado is the one
that's driving the ball to right center
and then kind of pulling the off speed
but he's uh
he's pulled the ball really well his
whole career
we saw him do the damage there in the
first inning to drive home edmond
and he doesn't bite
on that pitch from rasmussen
a ball in a strike i think now's the
time too matt to let us know about your
relationship with nolan i was on radio
this morning with
randy and michelle on 101 in st louis
and they said you got to ask matt about
how he was the biggest part of nolan
aronado coming to saint louis is that
true
i don't know if that was the biggest
part
nolan obviously and i are close and we
talked about playing in st louis and the
potential of him getting traded there
and and what that was like and the
excitement of being a st louis cardinal
and and everything that goes into to to
playing for the cardinals and how much
the city loves to loves the team and
loves its players and just the kind of
style of player he is
it just was a great fit so i wouldn't
take too much credit as he rips one into
left right there but it's uh he
definitely had a lot of questions about
being a st louis cardinal which i was
happy to fill him in on and he does a
little deja vu from the first inning
same work again pulls a pitch left side
10th two hit game of the season he's two
for three today and moves goldschmidt
into scoring position add this to the
list of pull side base hits for nolan
aronado
matt i have to ask you when you were
traded to the st louis cardinals
was it a difficult transition after
spending so many years with the rockies
well you know i had to stop in between
and oakland and any time you get traded
the first time the transition from going
to colorado to oakland was was difficult
and and first time you get traded is is
a little bit challenging but um getting
a chance to go over to st louis and play
in front of that crowd and the
atmosphere and i got traded over right
before the trading deadline and they
were in first place or close to first
place and
and uh in the playoff hunt so it was uh
it was pretty awesome just to step right
into a playoff race and and the
excitement of playing for such a storied
traditional uh powerhouse and and i i
loved every minute of playing for the
cardinals
goldschmidt and arenado on the bases
for matt carpenter
getting the start at second base today
single in the first strikeout in the
fourth fouls that one off okay matt i'm
gonna take you back
to your debut
in front of the crowd in st louis with
the ovation and hey
you loved the big moment
yeah that takes me back you know that
was pretty exciting times
uh you know i started out in
philadelphia i got traded on we were
they were on the road but that was my
first game at home and first at bat to
hit a double and it was a pretty
incredible moment for me one one that
i'll never forget and you know it brings
back so many memories and just
excitement of that moment for me it
feels like yesterday how about driving
in mark derosa for your first run better
hit for the red birds
you know that's not easy you know you
got to hit it pretty far to drive in
d-ro at that point you know you just uh
now d-ro is an incredible guy awesome
teammate uh one of my favorite favorite
teammates and does an incredible job on
the network and talking baseball and uh
yeah so we we had a nice little uh run
there as his teammates and and uh like i
said hilarious he's an incredible guy
mark derosa star on mlb network star
quarterback in high school too just like
you matt and matt your first 20 games
with the cardinals 475 22 runs driven in
i feel like that's that's pretty good
[Applause]
yeah i got off to a really good start
there which which was a lot of fun i
mean i i set the bar pretty high for
myself for the next eight years but uh
or seven years but uh i did i was i
traded right into a playoff race and was
swinging the bat well when i got traded
so
it was good timing for me uh going in
there and uh
it was a fun team to play on uh got a
chance to to bat in front of behind
albert pujols uh immediately i was put
forth and and immediately had tons of
at-bats with runners in scoring position
because they were not pitching to albert
so uh i got a a lot of at bats with with
albert getting the four balls right in
front of me
what makes it so special playing there
matt is is it the st louis area is it
the connection between the fans and the
players
i think it's all those things i think
it's uh i think it's it's it's very
important to cardinal p to cardinal fans
uh the the whole uh i think the region
loves cardinal baseball and i think the
history of the organization also plays
into it and and all the great players
and hall of famers and and all the work
they do in the community and and giving
back to the city of st louis it's just a
it's just a really cool place to play
and a lot of fun wong bobbled it so just
the out at first
two down in the inning could have been a
double play ball for milwaukee to get
out of this jam for rasmussen
goldschmidt is going to move to third
and arenado's at second after the ground
ball out off the bat of tyler o'neil
you know it would have been a tough
double player i don't think you're
turning
turning a double play on o'neill i don't
think you're getting him so i i think
there that turned out you know now they
have two runners in scoring position but
i don't think you were getting two on
that play dan
totally agree
as well as he runs
it would have been really have to have a
great exchange and that ball was kind of
taking wong away from second base where
he'd kind of have to ship this momentum
and throw back to a running target in
short
that's true tyler neal sprint speed
third fastest in major league baseball
right now behind trey turner and tim lo
castro good call
this guy has wheels too harrison bader
with two outs and two on for the
cardinals big spot here
as burns is out of the game and the
cardinals trying to pounce on the
brewers bullpen
good pitch
this is a big at bat for him you know we
talked to mike shield before the game
and he talked about harrison bader
laying off the slider a little bit more
this year and being relaxed in the box
and getting good pitches to hit and and
his chase rate i think is lower and this
is a big at bat right here this could
really add separation if he's able to
get a hit here a three nothing lead
feels really big
lays off 97 up
missed the first month of the season
with a forearm injury
oh for two today
two one
it's three and one
yeah this is where they'll put him on
and pitch to the pitcher
intentional pass now on the three goes
back to
here's the difference in the national
league and the american league right
here dan is that you get a chance to to
to pitch the pitcher and
and uh oh i'm sorry this is kinser i'm
sorry i thought i thought we were on to
the pitcher but you know this is a an
opportunity where you know you you pitch
around him to pitch to a 218 hitter and
and get a chance to get out of this mess
no question about it man it does make it
easier i think
particularly for starting pitchers
there's just this raging debate in
can you pitch in either league there's
just a lot the lineups are more deep in
the american league and this was a good
move right here
particularly with a young pitcher that
would have second and third first and
third one out
you fall behind three balls in one
strike they're more of a veteran type
pitcher you might let somebody like an
adam wainwright try to wiggle out of
that or make some good pitches but this
is the right move now ground ball is
pretty much a
force out at any base
it puts a little extra pressure on
rasmussen to get ahead to get strike one
but this is the right move
bags full of cardinals for kisner
and first pitch misses upstairs
dan are you surprised at all the high
targets they they uh they're holding
with the
with this pitcher it feels like
he set a ball as the target on three or
four pitches in the last two batters
where he's actually hit the target but
the cardinals haven't chased and it's
it's gotten him behind and counts you
know maddie seems like he's a four seam
guy that's up in the zone and there's a
breaking ball not a particularly good
one that's a hard break about 88 miles
an hour
but i think the brewers their metrics
their their their pitching and research
development department
they like guys like josh hater to throw
the ball up in the strike zone a
dangerous place to pitch
particularly now the shadows have
subsided so it's pretty much equal game
as far as the hitters and pitchers go
there's another breaking ball to fall
behind in the count
if your kids are right now you almost
have to sell out that you're going to
get a fastball right here
yep this is a big pitch right here
some count leverage for kisner
bader arnotto and goldschmidt are on
and that is sent out to deep right
garcia backing to the track and he's got
it
so the cardinals leave them loaded in
the six they're still hanging on to
their one nothing lead for big jack
flaherty back to the mound coming up
[Music]
ah
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
last of the sixth cardinals up
one-nothing ted klaszewski with the
sleeveless action and he could rock it
bo jackson a stud
both on the gridiron and on the baseball
diamond and frank thomas a big hulking
figure look at gabe kepler with the
texas rangers notice a theme here eric
thames give us your intimidating look
please matt holliday
a force at the dish
a i i heard actually matt and here's
tyler o'neill setting up our next poll
question who's the most jacked player in
mlb today two yankees judging stanton
michael laurentin
of the cincinnati reds and tyler o'neill
on this list matt i heard you were
such a physical specimen growing up in
oklahoma that when you hit three home
runs when you're playing with your
friends it only counted as one and you
had to play quarterback for both teams
when you were playing in the yard is
that true
yeah that is true i uh
i um you know i was big early i was i
was the big kid i was the kid that that
uh that got big at a young age i think i
was as big as i am now by the time i was
a freshman in high school so i uh i grew
early and and grew pretty big and
um yeah so i some of that is true um but
and weighing in on the poll it'd be it'd
be tough to uh to go against judge
having played with him and bid up next
to him and knowing how big aaron judge
is i'll take aaron judge on this one
that's fair daniel vogelbach swings
through the off speed pitch from jack
flaherty it's nothing in two by the way
matt listed at six foot four 240 pounds
in his playing days and dan please sack
six foot six who do you have on that
board
i'm gonna have to go along with judge
there are very few guys and i've been
around baseball most of my adult life
and i remember the first time doing it
30 teams in 30 days for
mlb network and going to tampa
when aaron judge walked out of the
dugout very rarely do i look at somebody
and go like man look at the size of that
guy
he just immediately gets your attention
he's one of those guys that walks into a
room and you can't help not seeing this
guy in a room he just has a presence
bogelbach with open real estate in right
center field and he's in business
heading for two
with a stand-up double to start off the
sixth inning for milwaukee
looked like a hanging breaking ball in
the middle of the plate
caught it out front drove it to right
center be interesting to see if they uh
they go with the pinch runner in this
situation down one
uh this run could be huge so eventually
to see what they do here and then they
think about moving them over
24.4 feet per second he's not the
fleetest of foot matt would you consider
a pinch runner at this point or not
necessary
[Applause]
well i i would if especially if you get
a strikeout here you need you need the
guy to score from second on a single
against jack flaherty and so
um i i would consider it if he gets if
he gets a punch here
and and you you got one out and a man on
second if if you've got somebody that
can come in and play first base
uh it is only the sixth inning but this
run could be huge and you get a chance
to to to get to flaherty who is very
difficult um it might be an important
base runner
and shaw's been their best bat in this
series he doubled his first time up
popped out
in the fourth boy what good pitchers do
at jack flaherty sure is that 6-0 in
here he has made some really good
pitches this might have been one of the
best fastballs he's thrown all game
96 miles an hour down and away little or
nothing travis shaw could do with that
one
it just looks like his concentration has
increased every time they've gotten a
runner scoring position it just looks
like his his execution of pitches has
gotten even sharper
shaw goes fishing for out number one
vogelback hanging out at second
you know mike schill told us before the
game that one of the things he marveled
at about jack flaherty is
his ability to step it up when needed he
said he's you'll see him cruising around
92 93 miles an hour but there's some
reserve in that tank when he needs it he
get it up there 95-96
made a great sequence of pitches there
to travis shaw started him off hard
96-mile an hour fastball did the hard 79
mile an hour curveball so we've seen a
little bit of everything from jack
flaherty
garcia homart yesterday actually
saw him in a pregame video kind of
talking to his bat knocking on it
calling that he's gonna homer in the
game and he did i love the lights on
lights off action two after the home run
in milwaukee that really put the game
away in the late stages for the brew
crew in a win they've split the series
these two this is the rubber match today
before they head their separate ways but
avasale garcia is on fire in the month
of may
that was a big boy bomb right there too
that's that's uh that's going
pretty deep back in there so that was a
hanging slider and uh he didn't miss it
that was that was full barrel right
there
442 feet for garcia last night what was
your
best distance matt do you know it off
the top of your head oh
i don't know it off the top of my head i
think uh
i i don't know i hit a few in colorado
before they had all the trackman stuff
so
um i don't know what my record was for
the longest home run i had a few in the
home run derby that went pretty far but
um i'm not quite sure
clarity quickly ahead man oh and two
[Applause]
96
oh he is and this is what he's done and
there's a reason why
the cardinals think that a long line of
great pitchers that have put on the
cardinal uniform they think he's as good
as any
and really that a lot of teams talk
about we throw that word around like
true aces but this guy really is a true
ace there there may be 10 to 12 in all
of baseball but you're looking at one
right here
chopped left side edmond
there's the second out
it's a food fight
mlb food fight presented by mastercard
will determine which ballpark food is
the best this year fill out your bracket
at mlb.com
food fight today
i'd like to get into some of that action
what are you looking for
well i'll tell you what i'm looking for
i'm a big fan of guaranteed rate with
the home of the chicago white sox
i'm all into that like italian sausage
thing with some french fries at a ball
game with an adult beverage
count me in on that
milwaukee oh yeah a little yellow
mustard i'm not into that whole onions
and you know peppers that go on the hot
dog or the sauerkraut but give me a good
hot dog italian sausage slash brought
with a little bit of yellow mustard i'm
all in
takes the pitch down matt your weapon of
choice at the table either
during the spread in the clubhouse or at
the ballpark if you ventured around
anywhere
you know i i think the smell of the
garlic fries in san francisco
i'm not sure that i've ever had any but
during batting practice when they start
cranking those out it's uh it's a pretty
inviting inviting smell i i gotta give
it to him for that i'm with you nervaez
takes another pitch similar spot
i have your longest home run mat in this
statcast time period so that goes back
to 2015. i know you had some long drives
before that but 466 not not too shabby
yeah that's not too bad not too bad i i
think that i might have had a few
earlier in my career that might went
just a hair farther than that i agree
based on the eye test and watching you
for those years in colorado
it's an interesting spot right here dan
with the base open and a 2-0 count uh
with a tying run on second if uh if he
really tries to pitch around him here or
potentially just put him on but he's
definitely uh you know behind the count
to a guy that has swing in the bat
really well you know that's one of the
reasons i think matt you see genesis
cabrera warming up in the bowl from the
cardinals look potentially jackie
bradley jr on the on deck circle
that's a drive to deep center and bader
backing up he's got some room
and that sits down the side
long drive off the bat of omar nervaez
but again jack flaherty working some
magic it's one nothing after six
[Music]
hi i'm chip carey major league baseball
announcer
and i'm skip carry major league baseball
announcer and i'm harry kerry major
league baseball announcer
that was a fun day my grandfather who
started in 1945 my dad who started in
1976
and then me who starts in 1991
almost 25 years apart
all doing the same game in the same town
at the same time there's the bunt runner
heads for third he doesn't even look
there goes to first he might have had a
play at third base
but boski he gives a sacrifice out of it
thrown out by boski
let's see if bosky slipped
when he made this play
and of all the things that have happened
to me in 50 years of broadcasting this
is a thing i'm proud to self because
this is my family
[Music]
[Music]
we're in the seventh in milwaukee one
nothing cardinals and the mlb draft
combine will be a new event for the 2021
draft similar in format to the combines
for the other pro sports leagues like
the nfl and mba the event is going to
feature three main components on field
workout off-field testing and
educational programming additionally the
combine will be structured to maximize
opportunities for mlb network and other
media properties to interact with
players and create new content to
promote the drafts this is cool and matt
you're a coach at oklahoma state first
off big w for okay state over oklahoma
yesterday but also i know there are some
players on your squad that have been
invited to attend that combat
yeah it's exciting you know i think that
it's it's been kind of a
it's you're surprised that they haven't
gone to it sooner with all the the
combines and the other leagues um so
it'll be interesting to see what that
looks like i think it'll be like i said
it'd be cool to see how it helps them
lead up to the draft and getting some
content on the players but we have a
third baseman named christian
encarnacion strand who got invited who's
a
big strong third baseman i think he's
got 15 home runs and he's one of the
league nation leaders in rbis uh so
he'll be fun to watch and track in that
and then we have a pitcher i think
justin robleski got invited to that so
we've got a couple guys that could
potentially go into that and and i'll be
interested to tune in and check that out
yeah it's the week of june 21st in north
carolina the mlb draft combine justin
williams is a pinch hitter so the
brewers say new man coming in it's brent
suter
[Music]
he
just smokes it
[Music]
[Applause]
great baseball right there
and that one's gonna
[Applause]
strike three
that was a great play
i talked about his fielding skills that
was remarkable
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
and something like this is what they
came for
[Applause]
foreign
brent suter pours in a strike against
justin williams the pinch hitter and
tyrone taylor in right field replacing
avasale garcia it's a one-nothing game
in milwaukee tight series especially in
the early parts of these games with
outstanding starting pitching we saw it
again today
and suiter works fast you love to see it
as he comes in and makes his first
appearance since returning from the
bereavement list he was placed on that
list on saturday last pitched in a start
on friday at miami
here we look at suitor he's a guy that's
very versatile and craig council likes
it because for the most part he's a
striker he's kind of a throwback to a
guy that would pitch in the 80s or 90s
kind of a low three-quarter awkward
delivery not overpowering
87 to 89 miles an hour it's breaking
ball it's it's kind of slurvy and
there's a good look at it right there
for some reason i had a chance to talk
with a lot of people in the brewers camp
a couple years ago and they just feel
like he's just incredibly difficult to
hit
he doesn't have one particularly pitch
that he relies on he's a little
deceptive and funky
and he walks williams the pinch hitter
leads off the seventh for saint louis
and we'll go back to the top of the
order in tommy edmond you know it's so
important now with especially when
you're starting with these relievers
with the
three batter minimum
the day and age of having that specialty
left-handed reliever for the eighth or
ninth you really have to make sure if
you're a manager we're gonna go to that
guy that he's able to get
both righties and lefties out pat murphy
taking over craig council was
given the hee hoe earlier in this one so
very important for lefties now to be
able to get both righties and lefties
out and switch hitter tommy edmond but
first to check over to first close call
there for justin williams
[Music]
yeah it's changed the lefty specialist
role i think a lot dan when you talk
about having to have a pitch that can
get righties out as well
brewers waiting to make sure they
shouldn't challenge this call
and suitor back to the mound now
it's christian yellow sitting there with
the bat in his hand he'll be in
nashville this weekend for some abs
i might have to make a trip down to
nashville
watch kristen yelach
kesten herrera
music city beautiful weather nashville
has always talked about as one of the
potential sites if there's expansion
we hear nashville las vegas portland
oregon
possibly back up to montreal montreal
was a great baseball city
also if you're in nashville dan you can
head over to vanderbilt university and
see two of the top picks coming up in
the mlb draft jack leiter and kumar
rocker as williams stays put
a ball in two strikes to count to edmond
yeah i got a chance to see both of those
guys up close we played a three-game
series here in stillwater against
vanderbilt so i got i got a good look
from the first base coaching box of both
kumar rocker and and jack lyder and uh
it wasn't all that fun for our hitters
let me ask you matt when you watch those
two young guys throw could you see why
scouts and organizations are so high on
both of these young guys
you know it was it was very obvious dan
when you talk about kumar and and how
big and physical he is uh that night he
pitched you know he was throwing his
slider for strikes he was throwing it
for chase
he was locating a fastball between 95
and 97. he looked like a big league
pitcher that night
and the brewers are not able to turn two
they get the force at second to get rid
of williams and edmond
beats it out at first
so yeah to answer your question dan it
was uh it was pretty fun to watch uh two
of those young guys and the stuff they
had
uh lighter uh was was was a little
smaller in stature but had an electric
fastball and and i'm not surprised at
all that they're being talked about in
the top five picks and
should be uh should be an interesting
draft and and like i said
uh that that night kumar rocker could
have pitched in the major leagues i'm
convinced that the way he was locating
his pitches
first pitch swinging dylan carlson drops
one into right field for a base hit
williams or make that edmond racing
around to third
and he's in there
that'll set up runners on the corners
for st louis dylan carlson attacking the
first pitch he saw from brent suter
looks like a little fastball in and uh
stayed inside it found found a home in
right field
[Applause]
great first first third base running
that's a great play by tommy edmond
putting the pressure on suiter in the
seventh
with the big boys coming up goldschmidt
and arnotto on deck
suitor's got to try to get a ground ball
here huh dan try to try to work the ball
down in a way maybe a change up down and
away trying to get the ball on the
ground
and not an easy thing to do because
we've been around the ropes as long as
paul goldsmith he has a pretty good idea
of what suitor is going to try to do i'm
sure he's trying to pick out a pitch
something at minimum he could get a ball
up in the air as strong as paul
goldsmith is he could take that change
up or a sinker away and
hit it deep enough to right field
there's your sac fly line
based on the throwing arm strength
there it is from the three outfielders
tyrone taylor with the best arm out
there
jbj in left kanan center
goldschmidt fouls that one back it's two
and one also paul goldschmidt has the
best numbers ever
at this ballpark of any player that's
been here american family fields his
o.p.s entering today
11.85
so he's feeling pretty confident right
here in this at-bat he's feeling pretty
good about where he's at his sight lines
are good i think he's feeling pretty
good about his situation he sees the
ball well there's your chance here
lorenzo kane lines it up
tosses home edmond racing in and the
throw is money
they got it bro
what a throw
ultimate accuracy amazing
job that ball
[Applause]
incredible job of getting behind it and
working his body through it to make that
kind of throw
[Applause]
it's the second time the brewers have
done this today one from kane just now
and earlier in the day it was aureus
gunning down a runner at home look at
lorenzo kane just perfectly placed for
nervaez
in stride with the tag on edmond he
couldn't avoid him and this game remains
one-nothing st louis let's stretch
[Music]
batting third and playing first base
from the st louis cardinals albert
is going to go down as one of the most
productive hitters in major league
history
basic pujols his first hit in the big
leagues
first career big league home run and
after watching this kid in batting
practice in that swing right there it
will not be nearly the last you asked
for how he's going to start his his
career at st louis should say well if
it's a storybook
[Applause]
114 home runs in his first three major
league seasons the most ever
[Applause]
in the air left field and pools has
given saint louis the lead stunned
[Applause]
is the fastest ever to 400
and albert
has tied
reggie jackson
with three home runs in game three
the cardinals a world champs
in 2011
strong pole question literally muscle
emoji the biceps let's show it off
it's the bottom of the seven cardinals
up one nothing and the most jacked
player in mlb today according to our
audience giancarlo stanton 31
he beats out tyler oh no sorry i'm
looking at this wrong tyler o'neil st
louis cardinals fans weighing in
as stanton finishes in second o'neill is
a big strong man he can run
super powerful with the bat speed and he
wins the pole today he snuck one by me
there actually his father terry was a
pro bodybuilder he's probably even
stronger than tyler as giovanni gallegos
checks into the game
and takes over on the mound for st louis
well one of the reasons that cardinals
are top of the nl central right now this
revamped bullpen and it is a very very
good bullpen
you know the brewers might have more
household names but
reyes has been terrific and
this guy you're looking at right here
he's been a tremendous out getter if the
cardinals bullpen continues to pitch
like this the rest of the way
this looks like i think two teams are
going to
duke it out
the cardinals and the brewers i think
you're looking at the two best teams in
the central right now scott
29 year old gallegos facing jackie
bradley jr
last pitched on tuesday against
milwaukee a couple scoreless innings 27
pitches
here's his second pitch to bradley and
it's a strike
he's got a really good slider i think
his fastball can get up in the mid 90s
but his sliders is outpitched it's got
more of a downward depth to it than a
side to side it's uh he's he can pitch
off it he can throw up for strikes but
he also can bury it for strikeouts
but he does have a fastball that he can
keep hitters honest with
there's the slider catches the edge of
the zone for strike two
you know in a day and age now especially
scott coming off that 60-game season of
last year where
the depth of every team is going to be
tested particularly at the pitching
level
minor league season last year there was
virtually no season so a lot of
organizations
both the brewers are cardinals not sure
how much depth they have that's
available and ready at the big league
level
bullpens are being leaned down more and
more early
you really have to resist the temptation
if your credit counselor mike schilt to
go to that bullpen early particularly in
april and may you'll pay the price for
it in july and august it looks like both
of these teams are going to be playing
meaningful games and i don't think mike
schilt gets enough credit for the job
he's done he's been an organizational
guy with a cardinals he's been a life or
a baseball guy
great feel for his team what his players
can do
putting his guys at good spots
looking at two of the best managers in
the game here today
there's the chase
gallegos picks up the strikeout to start
off the seventh facing the bottom three
in the lineup
you know you talk about mike shield i
think the the thing that really stands
out to me
is is the relation the relationships
this guy has and his ability to
communicate and build relationships with
his players
he's he's a tremendous man
there's the swing and miss from bradley
yeah schilt 2019 manager of the year
actually the only current manager who
never played pro baseball but a great
baseball mind
he's done pretty much everything in
baseball you know he's he's managed he's
he's been a hitting coach he's been a
field coordinator he's done almost
anything that you could possibly do
inside of a system and so when he got
the job as manager he sees things from a
lot of different points of view which i
think is an advantage he was even a
varsity high school coach in 1994 95 and
96.
one down and serious
popped up
carpenter
for the second out
so managers to reach the postseason
having never played in the majors or
minors this list is just three and we're
going way back for the other two dan
do you remember pants roland
have no idea but i like the look and i
love the hat
ed barrow awesome strong hat right yeah
i like it world series winners in 17 and
18 and then schilt you go a little bit
further down the line it took a century
matt to produce another manager with
that kind of track record and you can
see here manager of the year in 2019
joining a couple other managers big
names in cardinals history
yeah quite a feat a testament to him and
and all the things that he's done in
baseball and in the organization given
a guy like mike shield an opportunity uh
um you know john mozayla given uh shilty
an organizational guy who's who's like i
said has done everything in the
organization and has kind of earned it
like he earned his way up he started at
the bottom and earned his way up for the
opportunity to manage at the major
league level and he's done a tremendous
job and you know his right-hand man
there oliver marmal who's a close friend
of mine is is a young up-and-coming stud
of a coach and somebody that that knows
baseball and and i know that they're
very close and bounce ideas off each
other so i think they have a a great
tandem of manager and bench coach there
and the rest of their staff i'm very
familiar with as well and and they do a
tremendous job and they they spend a ton
of time uh preparing and making sure
that the players are put in the best
position to win
we had a lot of fun with mike this
morning on our video conference call
tyrone taylor lays off that 1-1 pitch
i think what's interesting too on the
call we were asking about how much
analytics play into it and he was saying
they give their information to the
players but they don't want the players
to be overloaded and and some players
like more information than others and
the key is individually like
give the information when it's there
they have their their research and
development and their analytic
department is very key in what they're
doing
but it's not the end-all be-all and i
think
mike has found a nice balance the right
balance to make his players feel
comfortable to have access to that info
but not jam it down their throat if they
don't want it
yeah i think that's a good point as a
player you know there's certain
information that i find usable and
beneficial but there's there's certain
information that that i i don't
necessarily know what to do with it
besides you know kind of keeping it
simple to what what works for me and so
i think that there's a balance of
finding how to use that all that
information and and blending a little
bit of old school and new school thought
nicely placed slider by gallegos
to load up the count against tyrone
taylor
who just checked into the game in right
field in the last half inning
ball four
two out base runner for the brewers down
a run in the seventh
and it starts at the top here for the
cardinals john mizaylock has been with
this organization for a long time
promoted to president of baseball
operations
in 2017 he was the
senior vp in gm named in october of 2007
13 consecutive winning seasons eight
post season appearances scouting
director back in the late 90s
part of the drafting of albert pujols
and yadi molina that worked out pretty
well this is a franchise that's just
done a ton of winning 12 post season
appearances from 2000 and 2015 which
included four world series appearances
and two rings they get the job done out
in the midwest well they do but i think
a lot of it is is the continuity and
that what they have in the organization
that there's not a lot of change they
believe in the system that they have
they're not quick to fire managers or
general managers
they believe in their people they let
their baseball people and their baseball
ops do their jobs they don't do a lot of
meddling i think john mosaylock knows
what he knows and knows what he doesn't
know and delegates authority to people
around him and that's why it's worked he
drafted colton wong as well who
flies out to right field carlson makes
the grab and the inning is over still
just one on the board this afternoon in
favor of the cardinals through seven
tell you what these colors are fire
though bro
i like these colors
when they first brought them
yes
they brought that new color like okay
so every time i put up clean my feet
just feel so heavy
uh
i'm wearing the low top parachutes
i was thinking of going to the vapors
but
you can't customize those i'm like
all about the look
hey
oh i need to get in that cage now i
guess i'm working
right here sir
we'll check one out real quick
i'm gonna find a barrel pretty soon
oh yeah
that's what i wanted
nolan arnotto will lead off the eighth
for saint louis he's got a shot at the
mlb game of the week live on youtube
player of the game title ivaldi javier
buxton and smiley have won the award so
far last week's player of the game drew
smiley
picking up a trophy name engraved on it
got the youtube play button very very
nicely done and the players love it we
chat with them after the game but it's
all decided by you polling will be
popping up soon you'll pick the winner
and we will talk to that player after
the game as brent suiter gets right back
to work against arenado facing four five
and six for the cardinals who lead by a
run here in the eighth well you're just
joining us now
another knock for arenado making a
strong case three hits on the day three
knocks on the day the story has been to
cardinals scored a run early in the
first inning and yes corbin burns
finally walked to hitter
five innings for corbin burns one walk
nine strikeouts not too bad 58-1
strikeout to walk ratio on the year
58 strikeouts one walk for corbin burns
so far this season that'll play
well it wouldn't hurt my feelings if
nolan wins the player of the game it'd
be nice to catch up with my buddy uh and
and get a chance to talk to nolan so
um
yeah like you said he's got to be the
front runner although jack flaherty's
six shutout innings uh
are pretty good too
and the fans will decide nolan arenado
with a season high three base hits
in his four trips to the plate and he's
followed by carpenter who's one for
three today
the loan is the trophy real is that a
real trophy do they actually get that
yeah that's a very real trophy matt yeah
i know all about it
um it is going to be in the hands of the
winner and then they will engrave their
name a little custom action and send it
to them to put in the trophy room it's
very unique
awesome
a weekly ritual here live on youtube
carpenter fouls that one off it's
nothing in two against suitor j.p morosi
is at the ballpark watching brent suiter
just pour in pitches at a rapid rate
jp he does scott and he also has one of
the great nicknames in baseball
the raptor because of his very unique
delivery and here at american family
field they actually play the theme
to jurassic park before he takes the
mound that was his entrance music here
today suiter of course a graduate of
harvard university he majored in
environmental science and public policy
known as one of the strongest
environmental advocates in the baseball
family has really helped the community
here in milwaukee in the ballpark
talking about the value of composting
and organic and local farms
truly one of the most interesting people
in the baseball world a 31st round pick
as well back in 2012 it's worked out
for the milwaukee brewers and there's
the raptor at work
[Laughter]
do you have it down dan
looks convincing to me i'm buying it
if i'm not mistaken kids playing a game
right if i'm not mistaken he
was a cincinnati moeller high school guy
the powerhouse in football
if i'm not mistaken
i'll look that one up barry larkin i
think was one of those guys you are
correct
cincinnati
suitor misses it's three and two
jp i know you've got more on suiter for
us go for it
yes yes of course yes in fact i can
confirm danny as a graduate of
archbishop mohler high school in
cincinnati the same school as barry
larkin of course hall of famer
ken griffey jr an alum from that school
as well that's foul back
[Applause]
that school is stacked with baseball
names david bell as well cincinnati reds
manager
look at carpenter against suitor five
for 15 a pair of home runs he has
arenado at first
full full count pitch from the raptor
missed
two on for st louis to start the eighth
[Applause]
this copyrighted telecast is presented
by authority of the office of the
commissioner of baseball and may not be
reproduced or re-transmitted in any form
in the account and descriptions of this
game may not be disseminated without
express written consent
so really good at bat by matt carpenter
right there uh lefty lefty matchup uh
getting a first and second nobody out
situation that was that's a big at bat
right there in the top of the eighth uh
and looking to add on and get some
insurance runs i think
that that that could be pivotal and and
maybe getting an insurance run or two
here
tyler o'neil has had a big bat in this
series homeward yesterday and the day
before
checks on the first pitch does not go
around
and matt now he has bragging rights he
just won the poll strongest most jacked
player in baseball it was a tough list
to take down
yeah good for him good for him i'm sure
he'll be he'll be proud of that i mean
that might be his favorite thing about
this game today
i mentioned his dad was mr canada top
bodybuilder in the nation in 1975.
his father terry and yeah
father
tyler's dad i'm sure he's watching
dan do you think this is where the game
has changed a lot do you feel like back
in in the day that this would be his
bunt situation was set first and second
and and nobody out and a chance to to
add a run or two here in the eighth
inning where this would be more of a
bunt situation and nowadays i guess the
analytics say you shouldn't bunt but i
feel like this is a situation that 10
years ago might be more of a bunt
situation matt your mind root i was
thinking the same thing a guy that's
hitting 241 on the year he can run a
little bit too you can go ahead and get
this ball down and to put you just put
extra pressure second and third you're
gonna have potentially second and third
nobody out
a lot of good things can happen
uh i understand you know there's there's
a part of that analytic community that
doesn't want to give outs away
but i'll tell you we've seen it more and
more matthew i'm sure you see it at the
college level to get a bunt down you
have to make somebody catch and feel
that we've seen a lot of balls throwing
up the third and first base line on
potential fourth place
and you make it easier on the guy on
deck you know bader would have a chance
to if he could hit a fly ball have a
chance to get an rbi and you get that
insurance run now if he punches here now
all of a sudden you have to score with a
hit and all of a sudden the pitcher's
got a much more manageable
manageable way to get out of the inning
suiter ties him up for the strikeout a
big one the first out of the eighth you
know
kind of an empty at bat right here he
gets the count leverage at two and oh
then brett suiter comes all the way back
three consecutive strikes he chases one
up out of the zone this is four-seat
fastball it's only 89 miles an hour but
he kind of lulls you to sleep with that
funky delivery
yeah it's amazing that he's able to to
pitch up in the zone with his fastball
at that velocity there's got to be some
deception there
that he's getting away with harrison
bader in on the hands roller to third
and there's the step from travis shaw
out number two here in the eighth
there's another example too a guy that
doesn't throw all that hard you're
wondering how could you how in the world
can you jam a guy throwing 86 to 88
miles an hour but
what happens is as a hitter you have to
go up there you know you're not chasing
velocity you want to try to tell
yourself to stay back and all of a
sudden that 86 to 88 cutting in on your
hands
appears to be 95 to 100.
yeah i think there's some deception and
crossfire in that raptor delivery i
think raptors must have good cutters
back in the day with the
short arms and
and and carving these right hand hitters
up a little bit high and inside where
you would think this guy would have to
pitch down and away with these
velocities
jurassic park was a great baseball movie
[Laughter]
it's all about spin rate velocity again
he's pitching up and in dan it looks
like he just wants to live in there that
that he knows that right hand hitters
can't get to that pitch that was an 88
mile an hour cutter now we've seen some
good cutters corbin burns and jack
flaherty corbin burns is anywhere from
94 to 97 and jack flaherty some 95s and
96s and we haven't seen anything above
88 miles an hour yet from suitor kisner
up the middle juan tough play fades away
and he's got him
oh that's smooth
he's the best in the biz at second base
and that's why craig capital told us
this morning they don't shift as much
anymore on the right well i can tell you
this this is the play that keston here
is not going to make here could get to
the ball but the arm strength off
balance if the brewers come back and win
this game you can attribute to that play
right there from gold wong beautiful
bathe some air and the play is made to
end the eighth unscathed for brent
suiter and company his team trails one
nothing as we head to the bottom of the
eighth
[Music]
three two delivery
on its way swinging a
[Applause]
this series is
[Music]
[Applause]
just
fantastic this one will go down in the
history
there's an all time
unbelievable a leadoff home run by david
freeze he tied it with a two-run triple
in the bottom of the ninth he wins it
here in the 11.
[Music]
so
step up to the plate compete online and
crush dingers in mlb home run derby
download on the app store and google
play store for free today
we're in milwaukee this afternoon what a
game jack flaherty and corbin burns
starting us off burns setting some
records with the way that he was mowing
down hitters and not walking anyone
finally his first free pass of the
season after 58 strikeouts and that
leads us to genesis cabrera pitching in
the eighth against the milwaukee two
three four hitters the brewers held
scoreless so far today milwaukee leaving
seven
on base they're 0 for 9 with runners in
scoring position and st louis 1 for 11
with runners in scoring position 10 left
on base it's lorenzo kane to lead off
this last of the eighth breaking ball in
there for a strike scott brondan please
sack matt holliday and jp morosi live
globally on youtube this afternoon this
one's living up to the billing dan well
a lot of good young arms in this
cardinal bullpen this might be the best
of the bunch genesis cabrera
made some noise a couple of weeks ago
hit back to back phillies totally on an
accident
and uh this guy has a tremendous arm
we've seen a couple of good breaking
balls he'll get it up there 97 98 miles
an hour
once he starts to get a little bit more
refined as far as throwing strikes this
guy's a chance to be
what josh hater is for the milwaukee
brewers
there's another change up at 88 miles an
hour we've yet to see the good fastball
but trust me scott this guy can rush it
up there in the mid to upper 90s
this is a big at bat right here you know
you got the right hand hitter and then
the two lefties to follow if he's able
to get kane this could be a pretty easy
inning for him so this is a big at bat
right here there you go lazy fly ball
right field carlson camps under it
that's the good look at the fastball 97
miles an hour and the ball kind of cuts
in on lorenzo game
a lot of weapons for this young lefty
and i think the more experience there's
a look at josh hader
who's having another magical year for
the milwaukee brewers
this car to bullpen i think has been
it was a question going into the season
but if you want to talk about what has
made the cardinals
at 22 and 15 the bullpen has been lights
out
trying to bridge that gap to get the
ball to alex reyes who's been really
remarkable this year
it's really started to come together the
last year too it started to kind of
you know you talk about cabrera and and
alex reyes as younger guys that are
filling the eighth and ninth inning uh
you started to see it coming last year
and maybe a little bit the year before
but they've got some really good power
arms with gallegos and his slider as a
weapon in the seventh or eighth wherever
you want to throw him so it's uh it's
come together nicely and and reyes at
the end really allows you to kind of mix
and match in the sixth seventh and
eighth
there's reyes
two shutout innings five strikeouts to
finish off the game on tuesday a 6-1 win
for the cardinals in 11 innings he
struck out five and he was working that
slider finished the game with six
consecutive sliders to strike out
bradley jr and billy mckinney on three
pitches each and cabrera misses up but
you know you see dan many relievers
nowadays just say i'm gonna pick my two
best pitches and go for it cabrera is
rocking four that he uses consistently
four seam curve ball change up sinker
98 on the dot that's that's not fair
right there for daniel vogelbach it's
just a nasty pitch but good i'll tell
you what the brewers have been the
defense we talked about it early on and
two plays have really helped brett
suiter to get out of some damage lorenzo
kane how about an ending inning double
play right here
as he guns down tommy edmond on a
shallow fly ball to center field and
then his last inning colten wong this
one targeted up the middle for a base
hit
tremendous play and brett sooner
caught a couple of breaks to keep this
one at one nothing
and now travis shaw
two down quickly here in the eighth
dan this is probably his last batter
when you say if garcia comes to the
plate with a runner on and reyes is
throwing in the bullpen i'm guessing
this is his last batter they'll go
straight to reyes against the righty no
question about that matt what we're
seeing right now in genesis cabrera
we're seeing a young pitcher that's
finally starting to
to harness his control issues that that
at-bat that daniel vulgar bark was about
as nasty as it gets and
when he's able to throw that first pitch
in particular the breaking ball for
strikes it's nearly impossible to hit
this 97-98 i mean that's just
overpowering
there's arenado flipping the shades
on
and making the catch
easy work for cabrera showing off the
good stuff in the eighth inning as the
brewers will have one last chance first
the cardinals with another turn for
insurance in the 9th
[Applause]
deep left field his first home run
against his former team
watched it into the bullpen
you know he's loving it on cue he hits
the home run looks into the dugout going
around first base and says let's go
[Music]
carpenter one for four with a home run
against this right-hander and gets
another pitch to drive out to deep right
center he's done it again
how about that back-to-back days off the
bench three-run bob carpenter
matt carpenter takes this thing for a
ride
it's the kane a drive it back into left
center field lorenzo kane has returned
with a lean back jack
wow
that's a return
my presence felt early tonight for
lorenzo kane
[Music]
covet 19 vaccines are safe and effective
join the team and get the vaccine to
help get us all get back to doing what
we love together visit
mlb.com19 resources for more information
google cloud is helping to power
statcast with massive amounts of data
points to reveal new insights taking you
deeper into the game than ever before
google cloud is the official cloud
technology of major league baseball
we're in the ninth in milwaukee at
american family fields it's one nothing
saint louis eight hits scattered around
by brewers pitching just one run to show
for it from the cardinals they've left
10 on base but the brewers have not been
able to scratch a run across
first some run prevention mode for
milwaukee one more time to try to get to
the ninth and tie this thing up angel
perdomo is on the man to pitch the ninth
against a very dangerous st louis
offense
nine one and two do up and if you let
anyone on goldschmidt and arnotto are
lurking you know a couple of things jump
out to the graph of the era a little
north of six but how about the k's to
the base on balls
eight two thirds innings 15 strikeouts
six walks when he's throwing strikes
he's tough to hit
[Music]
66 percent for seam fastball uses the
slider 24 of the time 10 change up
tall on the mounds misses down
this is one of those guys where you feel
like maybe you should take a strike
start in the inning maybe get a chance
to get a lead off walk to get something
going where you can
look for that insurance run here in the
ninth inning so i think this is one of
those deals where elaine thomas is
probably going to take a strike against
the guy that struggled with his command
the pinch hitter
takes ball two
[Applause]
yeah no josh hader available today just
based on how much he's pitched this week
and that misses three balls no strikes
no
devin williams jp fire eisen
i mean you don't know how they're
feeling obviously you know dan you come
to the ballpark
and they might say how you doing today
you're ready to go but those are two
guys you might think about in this ninth
inning in such a tight spot and a chance
to walk things off down just a run you
know the
fortunate thing during the course of a
year scott you have to if you're craig
counsel you have to really be careful
that you don't
overwork it eventually you're gonna have
to go to guys in the bullpen even though
you're gonna have to maybe put a guy in
a spot
that you're not totally comfortable with
because you just can't beat your bullpen
up your big horses
particularly early on in the early part
of may he walks the lead off hitter lane
thomas and here comes the top of the
order starting with tommy edmond
brewers i think you're looking at go
ahead man
go ahead
no i was just saying i i think that
you're looking at devon williams more of
the closer today so
you uh you know you're you're probably
not bringing him in this situation
um but uh they'll be interesting what
they do as far as maybe bunning here
when you talk about tommy edmond and his
skill set maybe
you know
maybe take a pitch and flash the bun out
there and see if you can get this
picture rattled
there's a strike on the corner to edmond
[Applause]
devin williams two pitches yesterday
they've used him quite a bit this week
as well
blown save on tuesday he had been on a
roll up to that point six scoreless
appearances
entering that one
edmond to the right side and there's
wang with all the range makes the play
for out number one
and lane thomas moves himself up to
second
jp what do you have
scott a great at-bat by edmond and that
has been a theme of recent weeks for the
cardinals since mike schilt moved to
have edmond lead off and carlson in the
two spot the cardinals have the best
record in major league baseball at 14
and 5.
on the season they're 22-15 first place
in the national league central
milwaukee at 20 and 17 on the year two
of the best in the nl central matching
up today and a good one
you have two cracks you have at least
two cracks right here with the runner
scoring position right hand hitter
against the left-hand pitcher so carlson
being a switch hitter got a chance to
drive in a run again with a with a
speedy uh runner at second base and
looking for that insurance run
some up and in heat from perdomo
picks up the strike
one and one to carlson who's having a
nice month
my best advice would be not to hit it to
colton wong or anywhere near colton long
if you're trying to score a run
another big cut and a miss on the pitch
up
probably should avoid jackie bradley jr
territory in left field too maybe not
too close to lorenzo cain matt right
not a lot of spots to hit it not a lot
of spots to hit it i uh
i would i would try uh i would try first
base or maybe
uh third base uh but yeah you're right
there's a lot a lot of good defenders on
the field tyrone taylor actually has a
really strong arm plays a nice right
field
this is a team that's set up well
defensively just like the cardinals
here's taylor
entering the game for garcia a couple
innings back most outs above average
among outfielders this season the
brewers are ranked second of course
christian yelich on the injured list
he's going to take some swings may be in
the minor leagues this weekend
and the runner moves up to third there's
a stolen bag for lane thomas just 90
feet away from adding some insurance for
st louis with less than two outs and a
chance for a sac fly for dylan carlson
boy some heads up base running right
there he took advantage of perdomo who
was just kind of one looking coming set
and
was very easy to be timed and a great
heads-up job you're always trying to
pick up 90 feet
get into third base a lot of ways now
for the cardinals to try to
stretch across another insurance run
three stolen bases for the cardinals
today and carlson takes one in tight
that's a big stolen base it brings the
infield in now all of a sudden guys like
colton long don't have the range they
typically would so this is that was a
big stolen base right here and gives the
hitter a lot more opportunities to try
to score that run
if lorenzo kane watches this back and
sees the sac fly line he's gonna go uh
wait did you see what i did a few
innings back
yeah he's not gonna like that no seventh
inning
goldschmidt with a fly ball to center
and
just a money throw so accurate from
lorenzo kane
on the fly in stride to prevent the
cardinals from putting another run
across
he did a really good job of getting
behind it and giving himself a
an angle that was directly in line with
home plate so that he could make that
accurate throw
[Applause]
the brewers are a team that's set up for
run prevention we'll see if carlson
challenges any of their outfielders
[Applause]
no he does not that pitch sells away
and there are two on for the cardinals
here in the ninth
[Applause]
for more content like this visit the
brewers youtube page it's the best place
to go behind the scenes with the
milwaukee brewers be sure to subscribe
so you never miss a video just visit
youtube.com
brewers
well paul goldschmidt is going to have
another opportunity to drive in a run in
a stadium that he loves to hit in so i
think the cardinals feel good about
having goldsmith the leading hitter in
in in this stadium's history so he's got
an opportunity to hit the ball in the
outfield the pitcher's going to be
trying to get him on the ground and get
that double play it looked to me like a
3-2 change-up right there that that
maybe they were setting up the double
play
in this situation
goldschmidt had a go-ahead two-run home
run in the 11th inning on tuesday and he
just smashes the baseball one of the
best hitters in the sport for the last
decade with statcast powered by google
cloud 54 hard hit baseballs that's
fourth best in the national league that
means he just punishes pitches
especially of course over the middle of
the play
yeah you know what to me the stats don't
really match up with his hard hit rate
yet and so as a hitter there's probably
a lot of frustration he's probably hit a
lot of balls hard that he thought were
going to be hits and and then he's not
getting the results he's looking at but
really as a hitter you just got to
continue to process it out keep doing
the process keep getting a pitch to hit
and hit it hard and trust that
eventually you'll get the results
he takes the first pitch
apparently low
i know dan wanted that one
especially against goldschmidt one
memorable call for a hitter yeah runners
on the corners here for goldie
does so much damage in this ballpark in
the past there's a check to first ball
skips away
and in comes the second run for st louis
today lane thomas scores it's two
nothing
[Music]
[Applause]
that's a big run
cardinals catch a break
for doma with a little bit of an erratic
throw to first base
you see a look at it right here i don't
know if it handcuffs daniel vogelbach
you can still see you can see the
sunlight in the shade
it almost appeared like vogelbach either
lost that ball of the seats or the fans
it was kind of a throw that was right
around the knees the the high
shin area
it looked like he was leaning like he
might be going right there too it looked
like carlson had interest in stealing
that base
so it looked like maybe a better throw
might have had a play
the laid off walk leads to a run lane
thomas also mixed in a stolen base
[Applause]
see to watch the look at vogelbach right
here i mean it's not a great throw but
it almost hand cut it was
kind of like a he yanked it and pulled
it down
to the left of glove side
i'll tell you what if he gets lazy
carlson could swipe third base right
here too if he get he's slow to the
plate he looks like he's in the one four
to one six range uh with his delivery if
he if he one looks him again carlson
could steal third
in this situation as well
a free pass for goldschmidt
seven walks issued by the brewery
it's gonna give nolan aronato a chance
to solidify his place at uh as as player
of the game right here oh he wants to
talk to you matt post game i know it
he wants that trophy he wants that
trophy with the play button on it he
wants it you know nolan arenado he is
one of the most competitive human beings
on the planet
yep and i used to crush him in rummy
you'll have to remind him if he comes
through here
for the cardinals
they've scored in the first and now here
in the ninth
and one of their best is at the dish
their new addition from the offseason
nolan arenado
two on and a run home here for st louis
perdomo's 1-0
in there for a strike
if he wins this trophy the next time i'm
with him i think we'll make that the the
rummy championship trophy whoever no
currently winning rummy will hold the
trophy
and then we'd have to get your name
engraved on it we'll get a new plate to
put over nolan's
talk to the people
at youtube
yeah i know i know a guy or two that can
help us out
got some friends there arenado behind
one and two
steps out for a moment
tough to find runs this afternoon
especially early on against jack
flaherty and corbin burns after he gave
up that one run in the opening frame
three walks this inning issued by
perdomo
[Applause]
these guys can be a really tough at bat
just the the the wild a little bit of
wildness to them and the fact that they
you know they don't really know where
it's going so it's hard to anticipate
the pattern that they're going to pitch
you in these can be very difficult at
bats for hitters that
it's almost like that effectively wild
uh you know pitcher that you know like
he may not be even aiming inside but
might paint it up inside
like
that that's just enough to make you
uncomfortable if you're not aware
pardona's been all over the place we've
seen him he's having a difficult time
towards his arm side getting the ball
into righties watch this fastball here
he kind of cuts this one off it's a
four-seam heater that just keeps
tracking inside
i mean certainly a young pitcher that
not commanding the strike zone if he
could flip something down and away
curveball change up
[Applause]
and then he paints it up you know it's
it's that's what makes this a really
tough bat for a hitter is you know the
guy's just he's got really good stuff
he's just not quite commanding it very
well yet and so it's it's kind of an
unsettling feeling
14 balls 12 strikes
from purdomo in this inning
three singles today for arenado in four
at-bats
and he sends one to right center backing
up taylor and he's there for the catch
tagging up from second carlson he's in
there
and runners now on the corners for st
louis with two gone and matt carpenter
about to climb in
oh that's a really big out for milwaukee
right now if you can keep it within
getting a base runner on and maybe one
swing in the bat you start throwing a
crooked number up there you get down
three runs that's a big difference
with a guy like alex reyes who we're
assuming he's gonna come in and pitch
the ninth inning who's been lights out
this is really a big out you you have to
knock round with your
perdelmo
really muster up to try to get out of
this right here keep it at two nothing
makes you wonder with a left-hand hitter
if they might try something on the bases
here or maybe an early break or see if
they can get this young pitcher rattled
and and try to maybe do something if
carpenter gets behind an account
after already throwing a ball you know
past the first baseman
paul goldschmidt used to
swipe bases pretty regularly he was
all-around fantasy baseball superstar
there's a strike
[Music]
carpenter with a pair of strikeouts but
also a base hit and a walk
behind that one
[Applause]
yeah prodomo creates a really tough
angle for a left-hand hitter if you can
get that ball high and away to a
left-hand hitter it's going to be very
difficult for matt carpenter to stay on
that pitch
this is a tough matchup for a lefty
and the cardinals are down to man today
paul deyoung not in the starting lineup
and
didn't sound like he was available today
at an mri it sounds like we'll get those
results after the game dealing with a
side issue
that almost hit carpenter
nice stop by nervas
looks like goldschmidt still second
he did
[Applause]
goldie up to second
[Applause]
most stolen bases in a game for the
cardinals since september of 2019. four
of them today
helping to create action traffic on the
base paths
carpenter
to center
in the sunshine kane
yep he's got it so one across for st
louis little insurance they bookend this
game a run in the first a run in the
ninth and you figure alex reyes time
coming up
[Music]
ninth inning with the red sox trailing
by five runs the orioles on top five
nothing jeremy got guthrie back on the
mound
now hernandez drops the baseball so
things were cruising along for guthrie
he's only thrown 91 pitches and prolazzo
is not going to give this kid a chance
to finish we're cool crisp at first
baseball are playing behind him as ortiz
rifles it out towards deep left center
field and coming across the score is
coco 5-1 baltimore full count base is
loaded
inside and he walks in a run
here's the pitch swinging a line drive
right center field base hit two runs are
in and it's a one run game now
three men on two men out and a 3-2 casa
julio lugo
lugo chops it right side malware's going
to need help over his rave apply now
here comes another run red sucks win
boston comes all the way back a six-run
knife
[Music]
if you're looking for more content like
this visit the cardinals youtube page
it's the best place to go behind the
scenes with the st louis cardinals be
sure to subscribe so you never miss a
video just visit youtube.com
cardinals i'd like to subscribe to some
more statcasts powered by google cloud
alex ray is showing off the slider
opponents are one for 21 with 13
strikeouts against the wipeout pitch
well one of the big reasons why the
cardinals bullpen right now is pitching
as well as any demon bullpen we've seen
it
genesis cabrera was terrific gallegos
and this guy right here
he's been about as good as you can be
looking at era 0.47
the only knock would be in the
16 walks in the 1980s i like to see him
cut that down
i still think long term scott this might
be a guy that you see in the starting
rotation someday for the cardinals big
arm
throws hard good hard breaking ball and
he is taken to this bullpet right now
and one of the strengths of this
cardinals team
heading into play today the cardinals
have been playing great baseball at 22
and 15. their bullpen has been really
good that sounds like the plan still
long term to put alex reyes back into
the starting rotation hard to take him
out right now of this ninth inning job
as he tries to lock down a save for st
louis and win the series pinch hitter
manny pina starting off the ninth for
milwaukee down two nothing
get a good look at that fastball there
97 miles an hour so he can rush it up
there too
i'd also like to point out his sick
cleats you know i think the uh the the
red jordans with the yellow bottoms is a
nice look that's a great look it's a
good
call got to look good doing it too
oh yeah there they are wow
i wonder if he's been in yachty's closet
i don't know if uh those are yachty's
jordans but
they
i don't know if reyes has got the hook
up he might already have the hook up but
i know yaddy's got some cleats that look
a lot like that
gotti getting the day off today andrew
kisner the catcher
ray is 26 years old last pitch tuesday
in this series
and there's a strike
he finished out the game on tuesday
pitching in the 10th and the 11th
striking out five did walk three
kept the brewers off the board picked up
the w
slider time
yeah
just overthrew that one a little bit dan
i think that two strikes
they're so sad short
i think
i think that would be the next step for
him dan would be would be to be a little
more efficient with his pitches don't
you like to where you know he can he can
have some 10 and 12 pitch innings to
where he's not constantly having to
strike so many guys out
just missed
called low
and manny pina works a walk against
reyes to lead off this bottom nine for
milwaukee i'm not sure where that was
but i don't know one thing i want that
one if i'm on the mound we've seen a
couple of pitches
this is a strike all day long
well located 86 mile an hour three votes
it almost appears you know sometimes as
the umpire get full because there isn't
anything about this pitch that's not to
like
that's about as perfect to pitch as you
can make as a hitter i'm i'm really
happy to take my shin guard off and walk
to first but i think as a defense you're
begging for that one especially the
first out of the inning in a two-run
game
big swing and a miss from narvaez
well reyes used to working with traffic
so far this season and for the most part
he's been able to work around
it know it's matt touchdown i think he
will get better as the season goes on
but when you're getting acclimated to
the bullpen you sit there there's a lot
of anxiety you're watching jack flaherty
you're watching this game develop and
you're you're sensing that this could be
a game that
you're going to potentially pitch in and
it's so hard
at times for a younger pitcher to just
calm yourself down
you get a little bit ahead of yourself
and he's throwing hard and
it's a lot harder coming out of the
bullpen commanding your pitches
you don't have the time that you do as a
starting rotation where you can go two
or three hitters and find the feel for
the curveball the slider there's not a
lot of room for air coming out of the
bullpen
nervaez can swing the bat and he does
but he misses
and he falls behind one and two
i think it speaks to the fact that how
much his pitches move as well i mean
it's it's hard to harness that that kind
of a slider and that kind of a live
fastball sometimes his ball just really
moves a lot and his changeup has a lot
of run to it so i mean i think it's it's
aim for the middle with this kind of
stuff and and try to hit the corner so
he's got the kind of stuff that we
talked about earlier where you can
literally aim down the middle and get
away with it
yeah we've been talking about alex reyes
for a long time big deal prospect he's
gone through some adversity including
injuries
[Music]
he's ahead of narvaez
[Applause]
going up against one of the best hitting
catchers in baseball so far this season
just activated today off the injured
list was
dealing with hamstring troubles
and the 2-2 buried the slider and struck
him out
nasty
that's nasty
hard to lay off this here where the guy
throws 97 to 100 miles an hour nasty two
plane break you see this the rotation on
this ball down and in
nevada's regis has a fastball down and
he wants it get the head of the bat out
to it
that ball just doesn't stop breaking a
great pitch
[Applause]
next up jackie bradley jr manny pina
pina walked to start off the ninth
there it is again
it's no wonder the league's not doing
very well off that pitch
plus stuff on the mound for st louis
it's all been coming together for him
out of the bullpen so far this season
that's a problem he run into matt though
he's he throws a lot of breaking balls
and you throw one after another another
it's really hard to command that pitch
and all it would take is one mistake you
leave that slider up in the zone and
with one swing
jackie bradley can tie something up here
yeah you got to be careful against the
left-hand hitter you might drop it right
into his barrel
[Applause]
slider city should he be using the
fastball more dan especially if he's
trying to establish himself eventually
as a starter well with a lot of young
pitchers is what he sees he sees a lot
of swings and misses and if he can
continue to throw this breaking ball
right here
he's going to have jackie bradley jr
right in his back pocket
that's a nearly impossible pitch to do
anything with
there's another
back-to-back strikeouts for reyes slider
city yeah it is you know and i know
you're sitting here watching this at
home and watching on youtube thinking
how in the world of the brewer hitters
continue to swing at this ball that's
breaking down almost at the back foot
the rotation is so tight
it has the appearance of being a
fastball and it just drops and
disappears it's just nearly impossible
to read he throws it so hard
and you know it looks to me like he
pitches off of his slider his command
pitches his slider and his fastball is
more to show
at this point he can you can has a
better feel for the location of what to
do with the slider and the fastball is a
little more erratic so it's one of those
guys pitching backwards with a 98 mile
an hour fastball
there's the fastball it's clock to
center field bader racing in it's gonna
drop for a knock two on for milwaukee
here in the ninth you know matt in some
ways he reminds me of a guy that used to
close games for the cubs carlos marmal
who seemed like he was much better at
getting his breaking ball over for
strikes than the fastball and this is
one of the few fastballs that he's
thrown scott so maybe this is why he
goes to the slider exclusively
[Applause]
yeah it's middle middle you know middle
fastball and a fastball hitter we've
seen him struggle all day long with the
slider from jack flaherty and and right
there he gets a first pitch fastball he
was probably thrilled to see that first
pitch fastball after all the breaking
ball he's seen leaning up to this at bat
we'll see if he goes right back to the
slide piece
up against tyrone taylor
milwaukee
i think you're gonna see some sliders
[Music]
he did this the other day matt he just
said at the end of the game you know
what six sliders in a row
good afternoon or what is it good
morning good afternoon and good night
that's the phrase
struck out the last two
what
they say you don't you want to get beat
with your best pitch you know and his
best pitch is obviously the slider and i
mean it's nice to have that 98 mile an
hour in your pocket when you need it
yeah that was the heater
taylor's been picking up more playing
time since yelich went back on the
injured list
now down to their final strike
[Applause]
what do you think here dan he can go
anywhere he wants right now you could go
the slider down and away or he could go
the fastball up in the zone
he's got he's got a couple different
weapons he could use here yeah my gun
tells me matt he's gonna go to that hard
breaking ball down and away that that's
his binky that's his bread and butter
his little blanket pitch and he's
comfortable throwing it and he'll throw
it three four times in a row be very
surprised if there's another fastball in
this sequence will it land in the zone
or not doesn't have to for him ahead one
and two on taylor who was the man on
mother's day knocked in the winning run
against the marlins a 10th inning single
for milwaukee
[Applause]
this is where you know he's shaking off
kinsler he's having a hard time getting
on the same page where if yati was
catching i don't feel like he'd be
shaking
taylor swings through pitches up reyes
strikes out the side game over
slider the pitch to shore for the closer
for the cardinals as they pick up the w
and win the series it's a two nothing
final st louis ups their record to 23
and 15 on the year as milwaukee drops to
20 and 18. now time we have to see how
this thing finished up
our poll question to finish off the day
you two player of the game pick one from
flaherty arenado and edmond and we'll
reveal the winner in just a bit it's
time for the post game show 30 minutes
all about the brewers and the cardinals
right now
the mlb game of the week live on youtube
post game show is presented by state
farms scott braun dan please sack matt
holliday and jp morosey this was fun
matt i mean we saw two of the top
pitchers in the sport going at it early
on the cardinals with a little small
ball to create some offense and then
alex reyes shuts the door picks up the
save and the cardinals win the series
yeah you can't always predict what games
are going to look like in the major
leagues but i think coming into this
game if you just said two to nothing
pitcher's dual very tough to get runs
someone finds a way to score a run here
and there and and the bullpen comes in
closes it out
i think that that's what you would have
thought coming in and that's exactly
what happened
well you know what we had a chance to
look at at history this afternoon too
corbin burns hadn't walked to hit her
all season long five power house innings
on the year he did walk his first better
not a bad strikeout to walk ratio to
start the year 58 strikeouts for corbin
burns in one walk unfortunately he gives
up a run in the first inning on a base
hit a stolen base and a nolan arrow
drives him home and tough luck loss for
corbin burns he pitched awfully better
deserved a better fate and hey we
mentioned this at one point during the
game christian yelich is out he hasn't
played much in the past month and a half
he has a back issue and he's going to be
playing in some games this weekend in
the minor leagues to pick up some at
bats and see if he can get himself back
on the field perhaps as soon as next
week hello scott bronden please sac and
matt holiday is also with us chiming in
from oklahoma but matt so it's yelich
and if you head into this season you
look at him plus cast and hearing you go
those might be their two best natural
hitters they're both missing right now
and it shows
yeah i mean i think that their offense
is as the numbers show as it's been a
difficult for them to score and like you
talked about when you don't have coming
into the season i i would have guessed
the two and three maybe three and four
hole hitters uh when those guys aren't
producing like you anticipate sometimes
it's hard to score and uh they're going
to have to get those veteran guys hot
you know the lorenzo cain's gonna have
to get hot jackie bradley is going to
have to hit better than that they're
going to have to get yellowish healthy
they're going to have to find a way to
get some offense at first base
they they need offense but their
pitching is going to keep them in games
and they'll be able to tread water with
that starting pitching in that bullpen
until they get some offense going but
you would hate to waste some of these
great starts that they're having with
the lack of being able to score runs for
the cardinals they win it to nothing
they have the best record in the nl
central and their starter jack flaherty
was awesome again and he's with us right
now on the post game show jack congrats
on the w the team comes through with a
run in the first and then a little
insurance in the ninth let's go over
what you did today how did it feel and
how would you evaluate what you did this
afternoon
um you know i think it it helps so when
you when you get a lead you know
one-nothing lead in the first inning
against a guy like burns who's been he's
been unbelievable all year
you know scratch went across early on
and then uh you know from there it's
just about preserving that you know you
want to get the you want to get those
guys back in uh in the first inning you
know put up a good one two three and
then uh you know from there i had to
execute when i really needed to you know
there was there was some points you know
kids did a really good job of uh keeping
me under control
um
but you know there's a lot of points
where we had runners but they had
runners on and at that point you just
got to execute yeah jack i thought even
in the second inning with the lead off
double i thought all of a sudden your
velo went from 92-93 up to 95-96 so that
velo's there in a tank when you want it
i'm guessing
yeah i mean that's just that's just
something that you know has been worked
on about managing the game and managing
you know how it goes and uh you know
feeling when i want when to when to go
to that and when uh you know when i
might be able to just kind of sit around
you know 93 94 but
you know there's points where you got to
bring it out
especially in situations like that
jack it's matt uh good to see you man
good to hear from you uh love watching
you pitch
tell me about
tell me about your fastball so you throw
50 fastball four-seam fastballs we're
talking about it on on the broadcast
um do you feel like it's the extension
that you get out in front that allows
you to throw so many fastballs and guys
just don't get good swings off of it and
it looks to me like against right hand
hitters it kind of cuts a little bit
when you go to the first base side of
the field is that something that that
you consciously do or do you feel like
that that's just kind of a natural when
you're trying to get it over there
yeah um
i i think it just naturally does that
naturally sometimes it just cuts when i
go to that side
but for me you know the biggest thing is
trying to be able to just locate it and
you know there's times where you get
away with some that are kind of over the
middle but you know the better job i can
do of locating it and keeping the ball
down um that's been our big ticket of
keeping the ball down and staying down
there and good things are going to
happen when when you keep the ball down
around the knees jack today was a
special day a global audience watching
you pitch nicely on youtube six shutout
innings your team wins two nothing so
there's a new tradition in 2021 some big
names have taken home this trophy the
youtube player of the game the trophy is
yours we have a copy in your hands
coming up in just a moment and then
we'll put your name on it oh as well
there you go interesting this is brand
new 54
of fans vote for you jack how's it feel
is it heavy
uh it is it's pretty heavy
i guess this is cool um you know
hopefully we can turn this into a world
series trophy at the end of the year
yeah that would be nice right but what
do you think that'd be a little bit nice
well i know hollywood was one uh nolan
nolan to get this
well i know you were wanting nolan to
get this i can hear you inside talking
about it
[Laughter]
nah sorry give it to nolan so we can use
it as our rummy trophy yeah give it to
nolan i will i'll let him know
hey jack i'll let him know jack your
bullpen has been awfully impressive this
year do you feel like when you come out
of a game like this that your bullpen is
going to be able to hold it down it's
been really one of the strengths of a
good start to your team
you know absolutely those guys are
lights out there i mean you bring in uh
you bring in geo cabbie and uh and a-ray
those guys have been lights out
um and even you know early on in the
series you know housley's been really
really good everybody we brought out of
there has been been lights out so when
we come out with a lead we feel pretty
good turning the ball over to those guys
hey jack what about the run support for
you so far this season obviously it's
not something you can control but and
today it was just two runs on the board
and just won while you were on the mound
but how nice is it for you and we talk
about this all the time two occasionally
pitch with a lead does it change how
you're working at all
yeah i mean pitching with the lead uh
was something i didn't think i did a
very good job of early on in the season
and have done a lot better job of just
mentally you know
mentally staying on the attack and doing
doing the little things but when the
offense can come out and give you a lead
like that and continue to put up runs at
that point you just got to continue to
attack and and and use it and use the
use a big part of the plate and you know
more times you can execute better chance
you're going to have win the game
jack what do you talk about
when you talk about some of your hardest
pitches or latent in the game
how much do you attribute to your to
your weight program and what you do in
between starts and how much time and
effort you put in and what you're what
you're doing in the weight room in the
training room talk to talk to the fans a
little bit about what it takes to get
ready for a start you just don't show up
on the fifth day and pitch
yeah i mean nothing would be possible on
the on on start day without the days in
between those are the most important
ones you know you get that from wayne oh
he he takes those days in between real
seriously um but but something like that
being able to carry the carry velo into
the later innings and you know as you
get up towards you know around 100
pitches which has seemed to become the
benchmark but
you know for us we've had guys go 120
it just depends you know certain days
it's going to be different some days
you're going to have 100 intakes some
days you're going to have 120
but being able to maintain that velo you
know it goes back to those days in the
off season
um and it goes back to those days in
between of the constant work that that
you got to do to that you have to do to
just you know get ready for that fifth
day and but but things don't happen
without those days in between jack keep
it up you earned a little extra
something today that's in your hands
tell nolan it's mine you have to earn
your own later on in the season two
congrats on being the youtube player of
the game we could show it off that see
there's the play button right there
you like it there you go right on top
nice yeah i love it nice jack thank you
so much we appreciate it man all right
good luck the rest of the way
thank you appreciate it
that's our youtube player of the game
jack flaherty he was great and look at
him go last seven starts he's 7-0 just
seven earned runs in seven outings dan
in 43 innings one home run allowed he's
doing it all for them he's pitching
really well right now and i know wins
are kind of pooh-poohed nowadays but
you're looking at a guy right now well
on his way to winning 20 games in 2021
yeah look at him go for a cardinals team
that leads the national league central
23 up just 15 down on the year and they
win the series in milwaukee much more
coverage coming your way on the post
game show presented by state farm
cardinals 2 brewers nothing that's your
final on a thursday afternoon
[Music]
i'm living the dream
i've been saying this since i was a
little kid but all i want to do is be a
major league baseball player
just trying to stay focused you know get
through school do everything that i
possibly can to make it here there's
still a lot of work to be done but you
know it's definitely a blessing
he said to try to catch a low like a
shoestring catch yeah i'm going backward
now do you stay there though
i would have beaten him back in the day
ain't faster than me baby
i think the biggest thing is you're
talking to guys who've been playing for
you know a very very long time and the
fact that you know they are open to
expressing their own knowledge and
things that they've been through i mean
it doesn't get better than that
the best thing i can do is continue just
to ask questions and try to soak up as
much as i can hopefully that helps me
you know just going into the future
[Music]
we're in the post game show presented by
state farm i thought the fire ball
review put it well beautiful traditional
national league contest today and this
is how it went down
[Applause]
well there it is the man of the hour
corbin burns 29 in the third innings
that's right no walks 49 strikeouts
carlson's had big numbers in the first
inning carlson
facing a 3-2 count statcast powered by
google cloud shows us how corbin burns
likes to handle his business
with three ball counts dan cutters and
he stays in the zone well that just
shows you how much confidence he has in
that pitch a couple years ago back to
2019
he was basically a four-seed fastball
guy up in the zone so he's not afraid to
run deep counts go to that cutter three
and two
[Applause]
and carlson chase is 97 that dips down
and it's the first out of the day well
the streak's alive he's yet to walk a
hitter evan is on third base for nolan
arnotto now arenado gets one pass short
and that's gonna break the ice for the
cardinals
nolan arenado makes it one nothing as
edmond scores
two hits one run now for st louis and
here comes matt carpenter
3 for 11 with a couple homers in his
career against the starter for milwaukee
[Music]
and that one's lifted to shallow center
kane racing in gonna be a tough play and
it drops and aronado is going to round
third here comes the throw and it is
in time
all right otto's toast at home narvaez
slaps on the tag jack flaherty for me
you look look at certain players that
were affected by the pandemic shortened
season yeah it affected jack flaherty
vogelback for the series is one for
three he has walked twice and struck out
one and two
that's a great play by paul goldschmidt
who plays a mean first base and gets the
job done three up three down in the
first for flaherty cardinals up one
nothing
o'neil bader and kissner coming up
corbin burns ready and here it is strike
him out swinging
burns with strikeout number two in the
game and the batter is going to be
harrison bader
and he gets vader and sets a new record
52 strikeouts and no walks
it's the most case before issuing the
walk
to start a season
he tops kenley jansen's record of 51 set
in 2017 and there you are he broke your
record as a starter
35
in 2013. lardy with a homer and two rbis
going 2 for 12 this year
here he comes again hey struck him out
swinging
and he strikes out the side
with a base hit mixed in there so we'll
start with kisner
good battle here for kisner and he loses
out on it to corbin burns strikeout
number eight of the afternoon we're only
in the fifth jack flaherty's coming up
who currently holds the record for most
strikeouts between walks but it's an
active race because garrett cole has a
number at 56 in a row he pitched
yesterday so burns passes him for now
then cole might top him later this week
and he puts away flowers here comes a
tie
tommy admin one for two stolen base in a
run scored edmond started the first
with a single only man to score today
and he's on board again
reaches for a second time and the streak
has come to a close
corbin burns has finally issued a free
pass for the first time this
season it just looks like his
concentration has increased every time
they've got a runner in scoring position
it just looks like his his execution of
pitches has gotten even sharper
shaw goes fishing crowd number one
vogelback hanging out at secchi cabrera
warming up in the bowl from the
cardinals look potentially jackie
bradley jr on the on deck circle
that's a drive to deep center and bader
backing up he's got some room
so he's feeling pretty confident right
here in this event he's feeling pretty
good about where he's at his sight lines
are good i think he's feeling pretty
good about his situation he sees the
ball well there's your chance here
lorenzo kane lines it up
tosses home edmond racing in and the
throw is money
they got it
what a throw
pitching defense and then in the ninth
inning a little bit of alex reyes action
oh that slider is nasty then one after
another after another jackie bradley jr
swings over the top of this one and
what a way to end it right here another
nasty breaking ball in fly ball to
center field
base hit
brew crew think they have something
going right now
but what reyes has done all year is just
slam the door not one of his best
sliders but he gets another swing and a
miss as he punches out three brewers of
the night one earned run in 20 innings
matt alex ray is getting the job done
again our state farm game summary the
cardinals two the brewers nothing so hey
that was i mentioned it before the
highlight matt
beautiful traditional national league
contest according to fireball review in
the live chat
and more on jack flaherty with the help
of stat statcast 3d powered by google
cloud
six strikeouts
and 12 put in play 18 recorded six
shutout innings for jack flaherty this
afternoon you know if you look at that
heat map he pitches down in the strike
zone a lot manager
told us before the game mike schilt that
he's one of those guys as ball has great
carry down on his own corbin burns more
cutters jack flaherty more down in the
zone but when jack flarey needed some
extra velo he was able to find 96 and 97
at occasion
did it have that classic national league
field that you love matt
yeah i mean i think that we talk about
pitching and defense and we knew coming
into this game that both starters were
going to be very difficult to score on
especially with the shadows taking over
i thought the roof being open and those
panels being opened i think might have
affected two or three balls that could
potentially have been home runs that
might have changed the outcome of that
game but yeah good pitching and then the
cardinals that's pretty much what
they're looking for a good start turned
the ball over to gallegos and then you
know that to finish it with with reyes
who's been unhittable this year so uh
pretty much per script of what the
cardinals were looking for with jack
flaherty starting and getting the series
win and then they move on to san diego
for another difficult series that was a
fun watch for us and for jp morosi at
the ballpark feeling the sun and the
shadows and a little bit of wind action
jp what do you think
scott dan and matt first it was a
pleasure to work with all of you this
afternoon what a great game between the
top two teams in the national league
central and i'll share this with you to
hear the ovation for burns when he set
the record and then another round of
applause after the record stopped at 58
was just great to be back at the
ballpark and hear that soundtrack that
has drawn us all to the great game of
baseball i just wanted to say how
grateful i feel to have been here today
and heard those those great ovations
that he got from the home crowd couple
more thoughts here the cardinals now
scott we referenced this during the
course of the broadcast they're 15 and
five since edmond and carlson now have
been one two you think about those two
great table setters two great switch
hitters ahead of the perennial all-stars
like nolan aronado and paul goldschmidt
of course they'll have paul deyoung back
at some point it's a very very deep
lineup for the cardinals you just see
the overall lineup depth right now
st louis clearly has the edge over the
brewers the brewers have scored just
seven runs in their last four games but
in a credit to their pitching they've
actually won two of them so they have to
for the time being continue forward with
outings like this from burns and
woodruff and peralta they're gonna have
to find a way to win games with their
rotation with their batting order now
having the lowest batting average in the
national league of course as you
referenced as well hoping to see a
return from christian yelich those games
at triple a nashville as you point out
very highly regarded in watching by the
baseball world to see how christian
yelich looks this weekend with that back
injury now scott we have to take a look
around the major leagues of course as
well here uh with our game of the week
on youtube let's now take a look at the
key headlines around now this this start
actually scott is known as the eighth
start of the year for zach please sack
oh no wait it's jared kellnick's debut
and logan gilbert's debut all kinds of
things happen with seattle soroka has a
setback there with his achilles injury
exploratory surgery is being scheduled
there and the oakland athletics
announcement this week scott that they
will be exploring possible relocation
hopkins again it's not imminent but uh
the announcement basically coming this
week that effectively says the current
coliseum site will no longer be
the the long-term home of the aids it's
either downtown oakland or potentially
somewhere else a final note i referenced
uh the zach please sack start against
logan gilbert there and jared kellnick's
debut out in seattle how about this we
have a travel baseball team here in the
great state of wisconsin out in waukesha
which is where jared kellnet grew up
jared kellnick's younger brother okay
waukesha wisconsin 16 miles from where
i'm standing right now plays on the same
travel baseball team as craig council's
son that team is coached by tom kellnick
jared's father so how about that the
same team uh craig council's son jared
kalanick's brother 16 miles away all
roads lead to this great place where dan
plisak pitched so many great games for
the brewers years ago news you can only
get right here on youtube from jp
working on his son tan what a day two
nothing cardinals win it over the
brewers we'll wrap things up on the post
post-game show presented by state farm
in a moment
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hit high and deep and this one's headed
to the water and
gone she was right she almost got hit by
it that's a that's a long long mccubby
cove shot
swung on
segura drifting out coming on his harper
and harper calling he makes the catch
[Music]
and sagura was right in front of him
maybe three feet in front of him and he
raised his glove as if he was gonna
catch the pop-up even though he knew he
was nowhere near it and they just very
very soft high five look out in the
vulpin tommy hodby purchased a net and
now the team has become addicted to
playing some pickleball during the
course of the game just to have fun
maybe some physical exercise that's what
mike napoli told me he uses it for
[Music]
[Applause]
punches that one down the line what a
play that's cross off lisa cross our
golden glover no cross up there
this is the mlb game of the week live on
youtube post game show presented by
state farms scott bronden please act and
matt holliday hanging out with you after
the cardinals top the brewers two
nothing and look at the schedule we're
laying out through july 9th on youtube
next week the giants match up with the
reds then the phillies and marlins the
week after one per week mets
diamondbacks dodgers pirates tigers
taking on trout and ohtani and the
angels the a's hot out west are going to
be in texas against the rangers on the
22nd of june the mariners match up with
the blue jays the country of canada
getting some action on youtube on june
30th and then july 9th
the reds again matching up with this
squad that we talked about for half the
day the milwaukee brewers who are shut
out two to nothing as we continue to
wrap things up here on the post game
show scott brown dan pliesack and matt
holiday great schedule coming up on
youtube as we flashback them for a
moment matt holiday september 19th 2006
paint the picture for us matt
that was my second at bat my first at
that matt kaine uh he hit me in the in
the top of my back and uh you know it
never really works where you try to hit
a home run and actually works um that
time it actually did i was trying to hit
it as far as i possibly could and it
happened estimated 500 feet benny no
who's a big fan and a big part of our
live chat
youtube creator says he and his dad once
dropped a holiday home run in the post
season
ah it stings maybe at some point matt
will set you up with a fresh baseball
but as far as the home run distance is
concerned because we were looking for
that about 500 feet that's more like it
matt that's what we're talking about
that was the good stuff in your rockies
days right
yeah i was gonna say that was gonna
reference that one is probably the
furthest one i'd hit um but again there
was i didn't i didn't think there was
any proof i'm surprised y'all found the
video from back then but nice job uh
it's uh that was that was a good home
run like i said matt and kane had hit me
in the in the back and and i was kind of
mad i thought he did it on purpose he
probably didn't but uh i
i uh i thought to myself i'd really want
to hit one as far as i can swing as hard
as you can and it actually worked
that's good i know you love that hey we
find everything here find everything i
gave up one of those to cecil fielder
hit a ball out of county stadium on me
matt so i know what it feels like to
throw one of those and it's not a good
feeling that is a classic and so is this
when we mic up players on youtube we get
great content throughout the game taking
you inside the game for the words of
colton wong throughout today's contest
mike check mike check my check
[Music]
check one two three check one two
12 40 game great time to start
i just woke up gosh dang it
you look good bro
what's up brother good to see you baby i
see you too how you doing man yeah just
watch out i'm a little mike dubs huh
yeah yeah
it's a nice beautiful day out in
milwaukee
warm 65. i can't believe i was playing
like nine o'clock in the morning when i
was a kid
wide awake too like ready to go it's 12
40 game man
youtube i'm gonna let you know right now
this game's on you if i have a bad game
it's on you if i have a good game it's
on me so we're good today
hey you're the biggest 13 year old i see
you bro
like the jersey might be the first one
i've seen very nice meeting you happy
birthday you guys take care
are you back today
let's go
come on baby let's do it let's do it
hey boy boy boy wired wired
you act like you say anything good
anyways bro
[Music]
hey that's a youtube original right
there i hope you guys got that
that was great
let's turn 30 this year my god i'm
hurting
i don't know 38 note
oh let's get pretty back
i said let's play pretty back on him so
you know he's going to try and shoot it
this way if he gets a chance
or that way
[Applause]
tell you what there's a lot of dudes
here with their shirts off kind of weird
oh the grand finale from colton wong
that's so good updated nl central
standings cardinals the best 23-15
brewers in the two spot at 2018. wow so
much good content to choose from right
there from colton wong including that
little that little beat song from brent
suter in the dugout bringing it too yeah
you know that's kind of good you get to
go inside that dugout see what goes on
here the conversations and the lingo
between the players is kind of cool matt
is that what was going on for your whole
life during the baseball uh career
i don't remember any of the music um i
don't remember any of the banging of the
music but uh there is definitely uh some
kid-like behavior that goes on so it you
have to keep it light you're together a
lot you're uh you're grinding you're
you're uh there's a lot of frustration
involved in baseball so you need those
guys that that can bring the sense of
humor and can bring the the fun to the
park every day and and like i said
there's there's a lot of kid like
shenanigans oh matt you brought it today
first game broadcast we loved it did you
have fun
oh it's great i appreciate you guys
having me you guys are pros and i
appreciate you guys letting me come on
hey we really loved having you and good
luck the rest of the season with the
coaching staff over at oklahoma state
keep those w's coming and we'll chat
hopefully again soon all right
all right thanks guys appreciate it matt
holiday and and please sack with us
today along with jp morozzi the mlb game
of the week live on youtube back on the
same day next week thursday may 20th
another nl central member the reds
hosting the san francisco giants
coverage starts rolling with our
pre-game show at noon eastern so we'll
talk again then for the ultra durable
dan fleece act today and the super human
strength of matt holliday mr midwest j.p
morosi and our entire superstar crew i'm
scott braun logging out for now we'll
see you next time on youtube
uh
[Music]
you